we got a bunch of videos coming out of
china
shanghai apparently several
neighborhoods people are filming
many other people on their balconies
screaming and it's not just screaming
some people are just screaming but it's
shrieking it's wailing there's a video
of some woman screaming throwing her
food in some kind of lockdown center
banging on on a bed
there are horrifying videos coming out
of china right now and it's a
combination of the extreme coveted
lockdowns they're going through wow it's
like a rerun of 2020
but also the food shortages
we're hearing that uh there's
serious food shortages in shanghai
there's a photo someone posted where
they open their refrigerator push it
onto their balcony it's completely empty
now the scary thing about this is a lot
of people in america are
they're biased there's an optimism bias
is a normal c bias it can't happen here
it can't but you got to understand we're
closer than uh people realize maybe it
won't happen i'm not telling you that
the end is nigh and to scream or
anything like that but we're gonna look
at some of these videos and it's pretty
scary stuff we got a bunch of other
stories as well coveted lockdowns may be
coming back to the us i know our good
friend luke rudkowski had said to us
it's not gonna happen they're gonna ease
up i said it was gonna happen but then
when we started seeing all the lockdowns
get lifted i said i guess i was wrong
philadelphia is reintroducing their mass
mandates we're getting warnings again
from the cdc that covet is spiking so
it's entirely possible we do get more of
these mandates plus you know we're going
to make fun of our good friend joe biden
who uh what what what do you say is that
tobacco companies wouldn't be able to
sue prostitutes or something or no yeah
yeah something along those lines or it
couldn't be prostitute yes thank you joe
biden great all right we got a lot of
talk about joining us today as we are
live in nashville we are at the daily
wire studios but you know we're actually
in our mobile command center 2.0 we've
got john rich how's it going man
would you like to introduce yourself
yeah john rich uh you might know me from
a duel called big and rich which one i
think we have one of the silliest songs
of all time called save a horse riding
yeah
if you've never heard it go look it up
it'll probably put
i've been here a long time uh written
thousands of songs in this town and uh i
am a
i'm the son of a preacher grew up in a
trailer park in texas and i have a high
school diploma getting very small that
is my pedigree you can carry it around
with you nothing fancier but i'm a fan
of you guys fan of your show and i was
excited when i saw you coming to town so
thanks for having me on the trailer love
you i feel comfortable in trailers yeah
perfect you look good in here yeah
thanks man
yeah we got sheamus yeah thank you for
coming by i'm seamus coughlin i run a
youtube channel called freedom tunes we
make cartoons political satire i think
you guys will enjoy my stuff if you
haven't checked it out we're going to be
releasing a video tomorrow and thursday
tomorrow is about joe biden it's one i'm
very excited to show you guys i think
you're going to love it go there
subscribe check it out ian cross on over
here and can you hear the rain if not
that's cool but if so badass what's up
everybody welcome to the show it's for
my first time in nashville john thanks
for having me man yeah thanks for making
me feel comfortable already yeah
everybody's coming to nashville yeah
yeah seems like yeah i mean when daley
wire uh i heard daley wire was coming to
nashville i didn't know anybody really
there at daily wire but i just kind of
blind called him and said hey
when you finally get to nashville let me
throw you a welcome to nashville party
at my house oh yeah and they said we've
got like 160 employees i said well the
room i'm going to throw it in at my
house holds 200.
and it's got a bar and a stage and it's
looking at downtown nashville and we
bring the band in and rock your rock
your socks off they go let's do it so i
had travis tritt showed up and all these
musicians showed up and i looked down
and there's uh there's ben and candace
jamming and banging their heads yes ben
banging his head oh my god on the front
as travis tripp was ripping uh some
leonard scannard so
didn't you throw a party for us yeah
what the heck podcast crew is coming out
so i do i do want you guys to go hit my
bar while you're here downtown i'm
giving you a hard time on broadway
called redneck riviera you are from west
virginia so i know what you know what
that means that's the work hard play
hard crowd that's awesome yeah you know
you guys are young you can handle that
oh for sure i am stoked trying to stay
clean you know gave up drinking for lent
i i thought that for our first night in
nashville we should bring in a musician
and john perfectly fit the bill so i'm
so excited to kind of talk about current
events with a guy who has a music
background also i mean we talk a lot
about building culture i think it's
great to see people in the entertainment
industry who actually have positive
values that aren't acquiescing to the
nonsense that the left is telling
everyone they have to submit to so also
like good for you but solo that's what's
so great about it your own producer and
i mean was that fair to say at this
point yeah i mean you guys we were
talking earlier you know who owns your
content
i said this guy i own my songs i own my
recordings on all my stuff and you know
i'm very fortunate that i had a career
that
went well enough for long enough that i
could get to the point where i could
afford to do my own stuff you know i
didn't need the big companies anymore
and so you know when it comes to
artistic expression i now have nobody
telling me what i can say or when i can
say it or how i put it out or anything
else so it's it's the ultimate artistic
freedom i think that to be where i'm at
right on well let's uh we've got a great
sponsor before we get started head over
to
surfinginternetsafe.com and you can get
virtual shield a virtual private network
service 50 off for life this is a basic
layer of security for you as you browse
the internet it will give you that
protection from
hackers governments corporations people
trying to steal your data it is as i put
it uh you know we don't always think
someone's gonna break into our house but
we do lock our doors in windows so again
surfing internetsafe.com for that
virtual private network service and they
say their vpn service is compatible with
all devices it allows you to browse the
web safely securely and anonymously
using their global network of servers
and private ips virtual shield lets you
browse the webcam completely anonymously
so big name isps and other third parties
will not be able to monitor your
activity when using their vpn service
your traffic is routed through their
secure and encrypted servers that means
that any restriction censorship blocks
and internet are bypassed enjoy browsing
on a fast reliable secure and always
available network it's free for 30 days
available on mac windows iphone ipad
android or chrome virtual shield is all
the work for you your entire connection
becomes secure private and encrypted
again head over to
surfinginternetsafe.com they got a bunch
of different plans they got personal
family and business plans virtual shield
has been with us since the very
beginning so we are eternally grateful
for their support but don't forget to
also head over to timcast.com become a
member if you want to support our work
directly we're going to be members only
show coming up around 11 p.m eastern for
all of you who want to check that out
and you'll also be supporting our
journalists as a member so we got a big
team that writes news every single day
and uh we're grateful for their work and
we're grateful grateful to all of you
for supporting us as we endeavor
but uh don't forget smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
this show with your friends and let's
jump into this first story and i i find
it fascinating that uh this article from
newsweek is it's all bright and the
image they show just shows like a nice
blue sky when the reality of these
videos is actually horrifying they say
shanghai residents scream from windows
get drone lockdown warnings check this
out i'm gonna i'm gonna play this i hope
you guys are ready for some creepy
sounds cause uh here we go
[Applause]
okay how do i get this to actually play
well apparently we can't go there we go
[Music]
so there's a lot of people screaming
here's the crazier video check this one
out
this one is
shanghai residents go to their balconies
to sing and protest lack of supplies a
drone appears saying please comply with
code restrictions control your soul's
desire for freedom do not open the
window or sing
that echo is so creepy so i sent this
out to a friend and said you know who
speaks mandarin and they said yeah yeah
that's that's that's what the drone is
telling people control your soul's
desire for freedom welcome to the future
my friends how do you guys feel about it
uh pretty
pretty terrible no i mean look i i think
it's sad i think what's really striking
about this story isn't just what's it's
happening in china i think it's the fact
that
even without saying it there are some
number of americans who would have
absolutely no problem with this being
the policy in the united states we've
clearly given up any drive to have
freedom and it is sad to say that it
looks like there is a real chance the
lockdowns could be coming back
so a couple of years ago
in august of 2020 these videos started
going around showing people screaming
when i first saw this video on twitter i
said somebody got hoaxed somebody
somebody uh took an old video and sent
it and said look what's going on in
china and it was a rerun it was it was
it was it was a replay this person
didn't do their due diligence
so i pulled up the old videos they're
different videos
so this is new and we have multiple
sources uh confirming this several news
outlets reporting on it and it appears
to be true because there's more than
just this one video there's apparently
dozens of videos the creepiest
that i have not verified but there have
been reports of people filming
taking their lives because there's no
food there's a video there's a video of
people fighting in a supermarket all the
store shelves are empty people have
taken garbage bags and they filled them
with whatever food they can and they
start fighting each other in the stores
i i always joke about this with the food
shortages you don't want to be in a
walmart parking lot fighting with agnes
over the cast over the last can of beans
and i mean it jokingly but watching
these videos of people in china fighting
over food in the supermarkets is scary
stuff man i mean it's reducing people
back to a primal
state where you gotta potentially kill
somebody to eat
i mean it's as primal as you can
possibly get and you ask yourself why
why would you ever push people to that
point
and i think i think the answer
unfortunately is that there's really not
multiple answers to that in my opinion
it is it is a purposeful way to crush
people to such a point
you know it's the
nobody can lift their hand up for help
unless they're on the ground first
you know and if the government if the
people in power want to say come on grab
my hand we'll save you you got to put
them on their knees before they're going
to reach up yeah and that if that is the
definition of putting them on their
knees to the maybe the ultimate way and
i think it's really uh a dangerous thing
for americans to say that cannot
possibly ever happen
in america really let somebody shut the
lights off for three months and see what
happens in america well i remember what
happened in new york during sandy and
and i i'm just going to stress this
point man we're in rerun season guys
because these are the same conversations
we had back in 2020 with these lockdowns
but i was in new york when sandy hit
and the power goes out for an extended
period of time and there's people
standing outside of bodegas with like
clubs and bats
one person allowed in at a time i walk
in the store and the guy says all of the
perishables are spoiled don't take don't
don't buy them
the canned stuff and the and and you
know the like the sodas are fine but
they're warm there's no electricity so
it's like you can get you get cash only
honestly here in north korea he
basically kim jong-un rules by
starvation he starves the populace they
have no strength literally no power
because they don't have any energy or
their lack of energy from lack of food
they're crawling around on the ground
looking for food people die on the side
bro this is from yunmi park who escaped
i've listened to her story escaped from
north korea escaped from that country
escaped that's the way they look at it
uh china it looks like this could be
i mean do they even care about the does
the ccp care about those people or do
they want less of them
they had the one child policy before
they wanted less people that way well
they the only thing communists are good
at producing is human misery and food
shortages and then they just sit on top
and and revel in the what they have the
food because i'm thinking like oh
no it's it's
got plenty of food xi jinping's got
plenty of food right now getting paid
look at their central planners their
view of this is we don't care about the
individual we care about the machine and
if that means you've got a billion
people in china and they're thinking
this is so expensive and difficult to
maintain there's too many people here so
i'm sure they don't care when they're
looking at how can we streamline the
machine that is the chinese communist
party and this country the whatever they
want to call it
so you know the republic of china
people's republic of china if we want to
streamline this okay we can stand to get
rid of access
and then bring specialists in they don't
view the individuals that they starve
out they don't care they don't think
about it
yes and on top of that it's comple it's
totally impossible to centrally plan a
supply chain like that you just can't
know where resources should be allocated
without people being able to engage in
free trade one issue we saw during the
beginning or at the beginning of the
covet lockdowns is that even though food
production was considered an essential
service which wasn't shut down there
were still food shortages in some areas
we were getting less meat produced
because the packaging materials that
people use to send their meat to market
were considered non-essential so small
details like this are just going to
inevitably slip past politicians and the
bureaucrats they appoint to centrally
plan the economy so even if they're
making a good faith effort to get people
fed they're just not capable of doing so
right well and that there are
quantifiable facts in this country in
america
that that would lead you to believe the
only ending which is there are people
that want to see
food shortages happen in america a
couple of examples one they've been
paying farmers for the past two or three
years i'm from amarillo texas up in the
grain belt right through the middle of
there they're paying them
to to
literally mow down and bush hog their
soybean crops uh don't plant anything
this year leave it all alone and they're
like they're paying me more money to cut
up my soybeans than i would have made on
my soybeans so i'll cut up my soybeans
fdr what was it called fallowing fellow
why are they doing it you guys are
saying well they're getting government
checks to cut them up but why would the
government be doing well so there's
there's i could have the word wrong so
guys correct me if if i'm getting this
wrong i think it's can you look it up
fallow yeah
and the idea is something to do uh you
know i honestly i can't remember well it
blends the nutrients back down into the
right right so if you grow something
enough times you kill you take
everything out of the dirt so they'll
actually grow a crop and plow it back
under but we've been seeing uh some of
this for political reasons is that what
it is fallow is usually cultivated land
that is allowed to lie idle during the
growth season right okay this so that
that's the renewable system well who
owns more farmland right now than any
other individual bill gates why is that
what does he know about farming and it's
in the last few years he's been buying
it up and why did china start buying
corn futures like crazy over the past
two years
investors in the important context as uh
as for bill gates he may own the most as
an individual but it's not that much
relative to the grand scheme of total
available farmland so a lot of people
assume when they hear that it means like
half the country is owned by bill gates
no he owns a very tiny percentage of the
total but he bought he owns more than
any other individual
which still you know raises the question
why is this guy buying up farmland
what's he what's he what's he what's he
looking at in the future exactly an
investment what is it about food
production that he thinks is going to
become particularly lucrative very soon
here the people need to eat it yeah i
mean probably people have always needed
to eat that's a little tongue-in-cheek
that they're shortages i know exactly i
think he knew or at least he saw it
ahead maybe he just saw it coming and he
could he could read the cards or maybe
he knew you know he's very connected i'm
not playing conspiracy here i don't know
i think if you've got a bunch of people
who uh you know bill gates has given
speeches on population
uh control
you know different from reduction but
you know i wonder about his thoughts on
that a lot of people speculate by all
means but uh uh control where he's he
talks about how we need to reduce the
amount of people being produced there's
too many so he's he's talked uh there's
that famous ted talk where he was like
we can reduce population growth by 10 or
15 percent
now when you got someone who's coming
out and talking like that why would i
trust that guy on health advice
you're right i'm sorry i'm not i'm not
going to trust you on health advice yeah
if that's his long-term goal
is to have fewer people
right exactly
i'm not saying he wants anybody to die
i'm just saying like i'm not going to
take health advice from a guy who sells
computers who talks about how there
should be less people and not just
optimize not just health advice if if
you're an individual who doesn't believe
that human life is intrinsically
valuable for its own sake i'm not taking
your advice on anything there's no
reason to listen right he's a man he's
like a utilitarian mathematician i mean
he's like a coding guy and he's not he's
not a he wants to be a renaissance man
he's not i mean i don't think he is he
really
i don't know he's a salesman yeah i'm
sure he knows computers he basically
co-opted a bunch of code in the early
80s and then made it private and sold it
that's right he didn't free the code he
didn't no he did the opposite he's the
guy that took richard stallman in his
friend's code and made windows out of it
this proprietary stuff and then packaged
it and good businessman basically
poisoned the waterhole and and and
anti-viral software right that was his
thing you can only sell so many
computers but you can you can get a lot
of viruses out of those computers so you
know i want you to get that software
going you wonder over and over and over
you you wonder why it is that so many
computer viruses exist sometimes
because
you know nobody's going to my
neighborhood and just randomly attacking
people not not every neighborhood but
we we we don't see
you know maybe it's not as easy to say
these days but you don't see overt
political terrorism in the united states
to a great degree like you do in other
parts of the world
and
when you see computers being so often
attacked you have to wonder what the
motivation is and why why don't people
in public engage in this to a cert the
same degree maybe it's as simple as they
do the same amount of people commit
crimes as make viruses but viruses can
spread more and do more damage and
that's why we see it more often but it
is a lucrative business so i certainly
wonder how many of these companies back
in the days anti-virus companies making
the viruses
well we're like uh antifa window repair
like ryan long's comedy sketch
guys go around smashing windows and then
come back the next day and say right
window repair it's not a new tactic it's
why do you buy a 70 000 pickup that has
plastic parts inside the air conditioner
and when it goes out after 30 000 miles
it cost eighteen hundred dollars for
somebody to take the dashboard apart and
fix the five dollar plastic part they
know it's gonna wear out they know
you're gonna have to come in and get it
fixed and they keep get they keep more
and more money coming out of your pocket
it's it that's the oldest trick in the
book sell somebody something that looks
great but it has some kind of flaw that
you know they're gonna have to get it
fixed oh by the way we're the only ones
that can fix it or avoid your warranty
that's a busted system yeah absolutely
planned obsolescence yeah and and
disordered yeah yeah and what we hear is
uh well that's capitalism off what the
left says and i look at this this like
you know if you want to have if you want
to believe that capitalism can be
idealistic feel free to believe that
that's not true you're going to find
people who sell snake oil yeah the slave
trade was capitalist too right there's
bad things so
you know when when i hear people say
laissez faire capitalism free markets
are better and all that i'm like i don't
i don't agree i agree a free a freer
market is better but i don't think well
that's the thing about the free market
they say they call it a quote free
market but that doesn't mean anything
about what they say it's just a name
it's like when they say here let's have
the happy kids build that congress wants
to pass about like punishing a bunch of
bunch of kids you know
uh free trade is not like anyone can do
whatever they want it's heavily
regulated only certain people can do it
no no but i'm talking about a true fair
free market where
you know uh buyer be aware kavet and tor
people are are there's a lot of good
arguments i've heard about how
competition will solve a lot of these
issues but you also will get uh planned
obsolescence the counter argument to
that is well then the company that makes
the better light bulb that lasts forever
will will sell more but then my argument
to that is what if one person discovers
the creation you know invents the light
bulb and then
they're making it and other people
haven't figured it out for 10 years so
they create planned obsolescence and
what's what's to say that the other
companies don't just say well why would
i step on the toes of a guy who's
figured out how to get people to buy
light bulbs non-stop why wouldn't they
just say i'm going to do his same
business and just lie to customers and
say it's better yeah oh no you go no
what do you think big pharma is
i mean healthy patients don't make them
any money and dead patients don't make
them any money but patients that we're
keeping alive make a lot of money check
out so
let me let me show you this post here
from bbc world service check this out
why china's zero coveted policy and
shanghai's strict lockdown is in
everybody's interest according to
epidemiologist dr eric ding oh yeah i
know uh no thank you no remember what i
said at the beginning of the show yeah
what was that well just that there are a
lot of people in america and in the west
who are completely comfortable with
these kind of tactics to eliminate covet
zero code is disturbing man you can't
zero the flu i don't know why they're
trying to zero covid yeah it's here to
stay as far as i can tell it's what
we've been told yeah well then the
question is are they trying to zero
cover let me you know let me just say to
the point this this is uh this bbc story
i guess it's like it's like a podcast so
i'm not gonna play their podcast but uh
this dr eric ding guy saying it's in
everybody's interest i hope that's out
of context i i sincerely hope what he
means is specifically for china and not
for us
because if the reference if the idea is
we here in the united states should be
locked in our homes for a week and told
we cannot leave for any reason and we
will not be given food
well americans i think would act quite a
bit differently than the chinese you
know you think yeah second amendment
yeah yeah people won't silently starve
to death here
in the cities
i think in the cities they would do as
they're told
i think out in the country people are
going to be like depends on the
neighborhood cities they're going to be
getting the hell out of their apartments
and coming out to the country to see
where all the people have the resources
and that's where you're going to have
the problems yeah right there starving
migrants well yeah but people out hungry
desperate people leaving cities going
out to where there is resources so yeah
what happens when that happens yeah like
so this is something
so this is this is the question then
what we see in china is
horrifying people screaming out their
balconies the drones saying control your
souls you know urge for freedom or
whatever
if people in big cities if it does come
to the point where you know what a joe
biden call it a global famine if the
food shortages do get that bad if the
food inflation is as bad as people think
it is and it's bad if it's if it's as
bad as people think it is
are these city people gonna run to the
country because the question becomes
second amendment
if if i've got chickens and i do chicken
city chicken citylive.com and someone
comes and they're hungry
you're not touching my animals because
we we have these animals we cultivate
livestock so that we can survive
if someone comes and thinks i'm going to
steal that well people out in the
country are going to be like i got to
defend my property my friends and my
family you can't just let anybody come
and steal your stuff
what happens yes do they do they load up
do they
do people start fighting right
yeah well i just want to say this the
sort of the the city urban liberal types
the dumb yuppies they'll just sort of be
sitting ducks they'll stay in their
apartment when they're told to these
aren't independent thinkers but when
you're looking at the neighborhoods with
high crime rates where people do uh you
know own guns or at least the criminals
own guns and there's more of a gang
presence they will absolutely start
moving out into more rural areas and
search for food and you'll see some
ugliness if we ever get to a point where
there is massive food inflation that's
starving people so let me ask real quick
uh
chicago
what city uh hoca falls yeah where did
you go up john amarillo texas so what
what what is that like is that is that
big city urban skyscraper if it wasn't
for i-40 there would be no amarillo
texas
especially if you look at the state of
texas go to the panhandle in the top
it's right in the dead center so it's as
flat as a board it's tornado alley it's
the it's the grain belt how many people
there's a couple of hundred thousand all
right so it's a decent sized town but uh
not how big is that akron's been well i
was actually from chicago falls a suburb
there's only 50 000 people yeah
but you grew up in a major metro no no i
never grew up in akron it was a suburb
of a minor metro how far away from akron
25 minutes 25 minutes and how many we
never went i went to akron like once
every three weeks this is called the
akron metropolitan area yeah yeah yeah
you got it you got a nitpick me i'm just
looking at that point it felt like a
small town town was so small they didn't
even have a barber you see
that's awesome well i'm just asking
somebody
uh being from texas i wouldn't call it a
small town or anything like that but i'm
curious what your thoughts are on just
second amendment people defending their
property
well what you're talking about is not
defending your property at that point
what you're talking about is defending
your survival of your family and of
yourself it's no longer hey those
chickens if somebody stole those
chickens or took my chickens or whatever
we're not in a famine it's not as big of
a deal but if i'm dependent on that or
whatever else i have for my kids and my
wife and my parents and whoever's around
me to survive then it's not a question
because then if you take my stuff we die
so it becomes uh the stakes go all the
way to the top when you start talking
about famine water is the other thing i
mean you know people forget that
electricity is what makes the water move
through the pipes into your apartment or
into your house unless you've got a well
electricity makes water move electricity
makes natural gas move electric
electricity makes fuel come up from the
gas stations it's a lot more than just
your light bulbs it makes literally
everything move so to me you know the
electric grid and some of these things
we hear about somebody is going to hack
the electric grid or whatever that is
honestly in my opinion is the most kill
shot you could ever put you were talking
about solar sure yeah earlier like the
best thing you could get or one of those
things a solar generator yeah i ran
across uh uh some solar generators and i
thought ah that they probably suck you
know i'm like ah i thought well i'll buy
the small one and see how it does so i
buy this little solar generator a
thousand watt generator
and it charged up pretty fast and went
okay let's see what it does i said i
wonder how long it'll run a freezer
because i got one of those big freezers
it's full of meat and this and that i
won how long had to run a freezer plug
that sucker in it ran that freezer for
16 hours wow which you don't even need
to run a freezer for 16 hours to keep
everything fresh you do it eight and
then leave it off for 16 and then yeah
just don't open it very often you know
so there are ways to get around it but
people need to think about it right now
yeah so uh there's this funny hit piece
on you know me and a bunch of other uh
you know trump pro trump personalities
from 2020 like where are they now and
they're like tim poole is selling
emergency food
and then i'm just like well
it's kind of crazy the mentality among
the left is that it's an insult
to to to want to have emergency supplies
because i'm just thinking like if you
think
it's like a point of shame like i would
be in ashamed of telling people like
make sure you get some emergency
supplies i'm not telling people to set
up a bunker underground with 30-year
30 years worth of beans or anything i'm
being like you get one of these buckets
you put your clouds you forget about it
i also think you should have a first aid
kit i think you should have some water i
think you should download a survival
guide onto your phone but man when i
when we have these conversations about
people in big cities being like oh
they're so dumb you bought emergency
supplies i'm like i don't want to be
anywhere near that city if it really
does get bad and the funny thing is i'm
not even prepper level
the preppers are sitting on their
bunkers you know smoking their cigars
laughing at everybody else because they
got nothing to worry about and really
the question is if you were a prepper if
you built a bunker if you bought a bunch
of guns if you've got stored food you
know how to start a fire and hunt
animals are you stressed by this
lifestyle is there something wrong with
that lifestyle sure you might believe
crazy things like the end is nigh if
you're one of these caricatures yeah but
really if you're if you're somebody who
lives out in a rural area and you know
how to survive you take care of yourself
i'm sure you're living your best life
imagine a more suicidally stupid
cultural attitude than it's dumb to
prepare for potentially going wrong
right and let's laugh at the guy who's
trying to build his ark before the rain
starts well i mean you don't have to
believe that the entire world is going
to end you don't have you don't even
have to believe there's going to be
societal collapse but how are you going
to sit here and tell me it's a worse
world if people have emergency food
storage but isn't that the story of the
ark yeah they laughed at that they
laughed at him
i'm not saying that we're going to be
seeing anything of that magnitude right
and of course you have to make that
perfectly clear uh because they'll clip
you and go look they're saying because
people should have emergency food they
think the world's going to flood also
global warming is going to flood the
world guys take that very seriously um
but that's a good one too yeah exactly
exactly um and so it's it's absurd i
mean even if there isn't some cataclysm
is it totally unthinkable that there
might be a situation where you need a
couple weeks worth of food that's
actually a really good point like
they're they they mock the idea of
emergency food
yet they're the ones claiming the great
flood is coming yeah that the ocean's
gonna rise by 20 to 100 feet yep where
you know and then barack obama buys
beachfront property it's so strange
because they have paranoid fantasies
that would put the most ardent prepper
to shame about how we only have three
months to reverse global warming or
we're all gonna die and they say this
every three months or so uh and then
they turn around and go look at this
guy's trying to sell emergency food what
an idiot what would you need that for
this is actually a really good point
yeah i don't i don't see conservative
emergencies of like there's you know uh
survivor company or whatever and they're
selling all this stuff like be a rugged
man and make sure you can survive in the
wilderness i don't see any of these
companies saying global warming will
wipe us all out you need to because
certainly that's a path towards selling
your product right they should you know
we should do i'm going to do this i'm
going to create a liberal prepper
company yeah i'm gonna market only to
new york chicago and la and be like
global warming's coming man are you
gonna survive the flood here's your
inflatable i'm gonna sell plans for
building edible inflatable wraps
here's how you build it so this this
goes way back why do why do city people
and i know all city people aren't the
same but let's be cliche for a second
why do big city people
mock and make fun of country people why
do they do that i think the reason is
because they look at the country people
and they realize that those country
people can self-sustain they can defend
themselves they can grow their own food
they are tight they're a tight-knit unit
they could probably get through a hell
of a lot more than you could get through
and they're threatened by it in a in a
way they're the alphas that are out in
the country they're the real alphas the
ones that are in the cities that depend
that are up in a skyscraper apartment
complex they they're the ultimate betas
because they're at the mercy of anything
that comes their way that's not right
but the ones out in the woods
they're going to be all right for a long
time i think they're threatened by it
and they don't understand it because
nobody ever taught them
how to actually take care of themselves
i know this is a recent thing in america
that people don't know how to take care
of themselves don't know how to grow
food don't know how to defend themselves
this is fairly recent you know the way i
think about it is
how long ago was it where a father
was armed everywhere he went and if he
was with his family he was ready to
fight for his survival like a wild
animal how like you know you go back a
couple hundred years cities are
substantially smaller you look at uh the
revolutionary period there's only i
think two million americans within the
thirteen colonies fighting for
independence two million across the
entirety of the eastern seaboard so if
you're a family man and you've got your
your homestead or whatever
there's wild animals everywhere so when
you go out you're armed and you're
probably wearing thicker leather of some
sort you're not just walking around in
short shorts and a t-shirt with
sunglasses on because everything's safe
and fine
we we are when you when you compare a
couple hundred years ago today it is the
epitome of good times make weak men but
over a several hundred year period and
now
you know we we talk about what would the
founding fathers think if they were if
they came here today and saw the
government it's like well aside from the
fact they'd probably freak out what
happened with the government they're
going to look at people and be like you
walk around in short charts some people
walk like women walk around the bikinis
and they're going to be like
there's animals there's predators
there's there's there's bandits
robbers and you just nobody cares about
any threats or danger and we can brag
and be like we've mostly done away with
so much of this through advancement
technology we're safe we have fat
homeless people and they'd probably be
like wow
until they see
any potential disaster coming ahead
until they see these people are
completely unprepared for any kind of
survival although maybe those come back
and eat big bowls of ice cream and be
like this is great yeah
we
we should hope not and i wouldn't think
so but
it is very bizarre how we've been sold
this
idea that the best possible way to live
is to move as far away from your family
as you can to live in a small box next
to a bunch of other small boxes full of
people to not have a yard to not have
space and to not have children to just
perpetually consume for the rest of your
life without ever
orienting any of that consumption
towards preparing for whatever might go
wrong i think it's pre-internet
mentality stupid it's because when i was
in the city i would when i thought of
people that lived in the country i
thought of a lack of ambition that was
what i associated with and because but
now that's i don't know just the way i
grew up northeast ohio kind of small
town my aunts and uncles were hillbilly
we all went out to the country or the
other farm hung out you know
apparently it feels nothing better than
squishing your bare foot through cow
patties you know come up through your
toes uh they told me but now with the
internet you just stick your finger in a
cow's mouth
yeah i still haven't done it yet but i'm
going and uh alex jones confirmed that
does actually feel good but then once
the
once the internet appear to change
everything you can run a business from
the middle of a farm in arkansas um and
also
i don't know i think just realism is
start to set in for me you know cities
are super dangerous the centralized
power grid it's like we were rolling the
dice every day and i hope i don't roll a
one because if i do when the power goes
out and if the power goes out for six
weeks
i have no backup plan and i hope the
roads aren't jammed so i can get out of
the city this is this is the crazy thing
about emergency supplies is i just tell
people sometimes it rains you know we
saw this big huge flood and i think it
was in houston i'm not sure where people
were trapped in their houses you never
know what you're gonna need did you did
you have emergency raft how many of you
had inflatable emergency reps now if i
told you buy an emergency raft you'd be
like what why crazy sometimes there are
floods do you live in a flood plain have
you checked maybe you don't but if you
do you might want to have an inflatable
raft you can and if you don't need it
your neighbor might right the neighbor
might need it this is the strange irony
in cities everyone is packed on top of
each other and yet there's virtually no
community and this is the question you
have to ask yourself if inflation gets
really bad if as biden promised there
are going to be food shortages do you
want to have neighbors who know who you
are and care about you or do you want to
be another face another name someone
that they have no responsibility to once
they're hungry i want to give a shout
out to our good friend uh joe biden over
here because he's got this tweet that
just went up today he said we need
congress to pass universal background
checks that's insane because they
already exist ban assault weapons and
high capacity magazines assault weapon
doesn't mean anything and he wants to
ban 100 round magazines or i guess that
would be a drum wow
and eliminate gun manufacturers immunity
from liability these are insane these
are insane statements let me just let me
just be totally real first when you go
buy a gun you got even in a
constitutional carry state you've got
the nix system nics was it national
instant uh criminal check system or
something like that you uh or check
system you walk in you say i wanna buy
the gun you gotta fill out your form
they say give us a minute and then
sometimes they'll be like you're delayed
have a nice day you can't buy the gun
because universal background checks
already exist you see what he's trying
to say is if you live in the mountains
of west virginia and you want to sell a
gun to your neighbor who also lives in
the mountains of west virginia he wants
you to be forced to drive to a local uh
gun store ffl federally licensed and do
the transfer that way personally i think
you're usually better off doing that but
i understand why you want to give your
neighbor a weapon because you live in
the middle of nowhere and there's wild
animals or you need to defend yourself
your property and there's no police it
makes sense that's what he's saying
banning assault weapons is meaningless
because what they're talking about is
like it's a pistol grip versus a rifle
grip and it's just meaningless high
capacity magazines
when you buy an ar how many how many
rounds the magazine typically hold 30.
30 rounds that's standard but they're
saying high capacity
anything more than 10
but when you literally buy the weapon
it's a 30 round magazine when you go on
the shelf all 30. you want a 10 round i
guess you can get one if you want to
make one but that's what they're trying
to do they're trying to reduce the
standard capacity eliminate gun
manufacturers immunity from liability
now that's just insane making a weapon
and then you get sued for what someone
else does okay all right let's eliminate
all car manufacturers liability yeah i'm
just gonna say or knife manufacturers
right someone gets stabbed with your
product you go to court buddy
you can't come after pfizer yeah that's
it that's the liability we should have
cult yeah you go after remington but you
can't go after pfizer or mcdonald's
pharmaceutical you should not in my
opinion have liability i think that if
someone takes a vaccine from a company
and gets really sick that there's a
court that'll protect these things is
ridiculous these companies like they
feel like they really understand they're
saying they shouldn't have liability i
think that they should be able to be
sued no i don't think they should be
immune from damaging people with their
medicines or with their drugs or
whatever you want to call them well
i agree there there's challenges in that
there's going to be side effects for
basically everything
and you know you might be allergic to
something and not know or you might be
the the one in whatever manny if so like
let's say you get like some kind of uh
swelling treatment and they're like
there's a rare side effect it gives you
rash you get a rash yeah i think
top-down medicine production isn't the
way of the future a lot of it's like
we're going to start 3d printing
medicine that's tailor-made for your
chemistry your body chemistry and uh so
this whole top-down medicine where they
make one drug and give it to everyone is
obviously not working because a lot of
people aren't doing well with it so i
have a story about nancy pelosi asking
me about guns in the backyard uh in
beverly hills really like to hear it
absolutely i know right that guy even
that your attention yeah let's hear it
so i'm back there i got invited to sing
at tony bennett's 85th birthday party
and i'm in the backyard of ted sarandos
the founder of netflix i'm in his
backyard there's john travolta queen
latifah and i are bringing out the
birthday cake i mean you can't make this
up i'm looking around this backyard
going
i'm not supposed to be here so i'm just
going to have some fun you know like
mine no one of these things is not like
the other so i'm back there and i'm
hanging out and and i see nancy pelosi
over there starts making a beeline
towards me and i'll be honest it was
frightening it was frightening
she's coming
and she walks right up to me she doesn't
say hello she goes you seem like a
reasonable person
i guess meaning for a guy in a cowboy
hat and a handlebar mustache because
otherwise you wouldn't be at this
backyard right you must be a reasonable
you seem like a reasonable person i said
well i appreciate that madam speaker she
goes can i ask you a question about guns
oh
i said absolutely oh yeah so vince
vaughn is standing there and vince leans
in travolta's got his arms crossed he's
leaning out great yeah everybody's
leaning in
and uh
pelosi goes now i'm not a hunter but i'm
pretty sure
that if i shot that first bullet at
whatever i was hunting and i didn't hit
it it would run away i go that's correct
she goes so why does anybody need more
than seven rounds is what she said why
does he might need more than seven
rounds
in their gun
and i held up my cell phone i said well
madame speaker right now back in
nashville tennessee i have a wife and i
got a three-year-old son and a
five-year-old son and we live right in
the middle of town
i said now she called my phone right now
and said john i hear footsteps coming up
the stairs i said madam speaker would
you advise me to tell my wife to grab
the one with seven rounds or the one
with 30 rounds
and her eyes kind of got big and she
said
is that the way you look at that
i said yes ma'am she goes
well it was nice to meet you and then
just walked off but for a brief moment
this light bulb pops i believe first of
all they know that anyway that's why
they all have armed guards yeah yep but
i was able to dead in her eye one time
say it's to protect our families of
course we only need 30 rounds to hunt a
deer and there's nothing in the second
amendment about hunting it's all about
defense good for you how many rounds
does that they're armed guards
right
what kind of guns yes i was just going
to ask they're going to have 17 plus
ones they're going to have 21 plus ones
they're going to have high capacity
they're going to have multiple high
capacity clips on their belts because if
something breaks out they're in a
gunfight oh and and i think uh when it
comes to the speaker she's probably got
a couple guys with short barreled rifles
no doubt about it no doubt about it so
you can confront them and i i would
always advise anybody if you're ever
talking to your neighbors friends about
gun about guns and clips and whatever
is that you have the right to defend
your family how you see fit you don't
get to tell me how i get to defend my
family those are my kids that is my wife
god put me in charge of them in charge
of their defense and if something
happens to them that's on me
and i'd rather deal with your bad
opinion of my high-capacity gun than
deal with a dead child or a dead family
exactly we already got a couple people
saying clips
yeah
magazines uh-oh but what's that magazine
it's that mentality that allowed us to
build this country the way we did if we
were all getting picked off at home
and the government had total control and
they weren't afraid of the population we
never would have had this beautiful
liberal society that we organized sorry
to use the word liberal i'm bringing it
back to what it really means which is
liberty sure um no i mean look the
founders make it perfectly clear in the
founding documents of this country that
owning a gun is a right that is
available to all people it is not a
privilege for the ultra wealthy who can
have formed our armed guards and
whatever paperwork these bureaucrats
would try to put you through in order to
be able to defend yourself but now now
john would you agree with me when i say
that second amendment guarantees our
right to have nuclear weapons and
biological weapons uh oh no i didn't see
that in there no i do i see it in there
do you yeah so i got in trouble because
i i pointed that out and
they they they take this clip of me
where they cut my full statement and say
tim poole calls for people to have
nuclear and biological weapons what i
said was the constitution says the right
to keep and bear arms it doesn't specify
what right and back then as a privateer
as a private citizen you could have any
weapon the government could have correct
that hasn't changed they wanted equal
force right yeah has that changed
well well we yeah we now cannot get our
hands on weapons that are equal force
but the second amendment didn't change
they just started passing laws correct
without
any uh
i guess legitimate questions as to what
the limits should have actually been and
this is what joe biden is doing now now
i i would not want people to have
nuclear weapons or uh biological weapons
that that scary thought some lunatic guy
with a bio weapon because of how much
destruction could be wrought but there's
a very serious question about
when do we draw that line and say
regardless of the constitutional
amendments we've decided you can't have
things
you'd have to amend the constitution to
change that that's a good argument well
i think i think we could easily amend it
to be like we've decided nuclear weapons
and buy weapons like we're not going to
include in the second amendment
right yeah let's take that off the table
well i think there's also another
serious question to ask which is why did
biden just decide recently that this was
going to be his next moral crusade the
country's falling apart we have runaway
inflation he's acknowledged food
shortages are coming and he's going to
sit here and tell us that his goal is
that is the end gun violence it's
because he thinks there's going to be
gun violence if there's famine mm-hmm
and wants to try and stop it by taking
the guns away so there's criminal gangs
running around creating mafia like what
the heck i'll push back a little bit
i mean it may just be he needs a
distraction it could be so you know in
response to biden jeffrey miller said oh
look a new emotionally vivid issue to
distract us from inflation and your
catastrophic monetary policy yep so
yeah they've been blaming inflation on
putin i don't know something i thought
was true for a long time that i found
out was not true and i wonder how many
gun owners think this is true
uh i'm friends with the guy it's been
the atf 29 years uh and we were hanging
out on a little vacation together and he
was kind of bumming around and uh they
were trying to it was another one of
these gun bills we're trying to get past
and i said man you know they ever come
door to door want to take people's guns
i said the atf right he goes john
people don't know what guns you own the
government doesn't know what guns you
own i said what are you talking about
he said there is no gun registry for the
united states of america he said here's
how a crime works i go to a crime scene
there's a colt pistol laying in the
street we have to get the colt pistol we
have to call colt the manufacturer find
out who they sold the gun to what store
they originally sold the gun to it could
be a 30 year old weapon
if the store still exists and if they
still have records going back that far
we can find out who purchased the gun
originally then we have to go find that
person and if that person no longer owns
the gun we have to see if they have any
records of who they sold it to and on
and on and on he said we would have to
do that with literally every single
weapon in the united states to know
who's got what guns so this is just like
a fear tactic they want people to think
that they know who has they don't know
they do not know now in illinois
california new york they have state gun
registries in those states and he said
those are the only three where they
actually know what guns you own yeah
which one
15 20 years california new york and
illinois that's why the gun crime's so
low that yeah right i was going to say
like there's something interesting about
those states was as it pertains to their
gun laws they also have a whole lot of
gun crime yeah well you know look
baltimore's got serious gun crime as
well it's not just those states but when
i hear illinois i'm like they call it
chiraq because of how many gun deaths
there are more you know there was like a
year where there were more gun deaths in
chicago than the entirety of iraq yeah
and their laws don't seem to do anything
to stop that granted uh i think it was
in 2000's there was a court ruling that
i think supreme court ruling so now you
can actually get a gun in illinois
though it's damn near impossible
yeah
i just found that to be isn't that a
myth though yeah didn't you think that
was probably true they just they'll show
up and go mr rich you we see that you
own xyz he goes we have no idea what you
want yeah in the movies they're like we
got the gun we got the serial number
we're going to run it through the
registry and they're like oh we got
there's a registry now when i see tweets
like that from biden he's talking about
universal background checks if he said
universal
registry
that's a different animal that's a
different thing if you ever see the word
registry but the background check is
probably the registry yeah that's
exactly the plan that's that's probably
the way they would word it in the bill
would actually turn into a register i
find that we're on the verge of 3d
printed guns like the 21st century is
going to be all about crafting your own
weaponry and stuff verge of yeah we're
in it it has begun the ghost gun is a
real product we have but the go the
ghost gun is you're just making your
weapon control pew we've had on the show
posting all these videos on twitter of
the guns they just make yeah how
effective were those at this point i
remember seeing some early prototypes
they know they were pretty lousy really
yup yeah the early ones they had to pull
the hammer with a straight they pulled
the trigger with a string from like
eight feet back so it didn't explode in
their hand because they didn't know they
were plastic they fall apart they fire
one bullet at a time but the new ones
are there was the first one you remember
what was called i don't know the
liberator sort of the little the little
white plastic handgun that was good for
like five shots or something but no one
one shot one shot
now if you if you go on twitter and you
follow control pew and you look at the
url yeah ctrl
and you look at all the things they're
posting
yo
they have unique designs and these
things work it's just it's it's no
longer like the old days they've figured
this stuff out it's like a whack-a-mole
i can see a totalitarian regime would
use that as a game of whack-a-mole to
just write more and more laws of how to
go after more and more gunman was like
dude at some point like you're stepping
on your own foot it you know we're
working together here
there's real problems out there and it
comes down to do you have enough water
and do you have enough food and you have
enough space to move around
decentralization has done wonders
with the internet one of the things
that's pushing back on the the
establishment cult woke nonsense is that
people who live in rural areas now have
the ability to uh to build community it
used to be that the message the
narrative would come top down from big
cities with big city intellectuals and
that was it community was formed around
their broadcast tower but now because of
the internet people can build their own
communities which is a lot which is
allowing more conservatives to you know
coalesce around certain personalities
certain media outlets
you have the same thing with 3d printing
they can't they can't stop it and i
think when you when you look at what's
going on now with the culture war i'm
i'm fairly optimistic
and and especially when you look at a
lot of the data
we have one story actually let me pull
up the story here and jump straight to
this uh the story we have here give you
guys some optimism
this is from slow boring which is
matthew iglesias's sub stack
he's one of the founders of vox.com vox
lefty here's what he tweeted
he said suppose democrats get 48 of the
vote in 2022 and then rebound to 50
percent in 2024 pretty normal but under
today's maps that means a gop trifecta
with 60 or 61 senators
you know i read this today and i was
just it's it's shocking i mean looking
right now at the at the current data
based on all the aggregate polls
and
assuming we don't see changes from now
until the election it looks like
republicans not only will win
congress but that if this track remains
steady by 2024 they'll have 60 or 61
seats in the senate which means they're
going to steamroll through basically
whatever they want it's not absolutely
appropriate because the republican party
is kind of yeah maybe if people go and
vote in their primaries this will have a
bigger impact
but looking at this
wow
can you have an election if there's a
famine
or if they lock things down again so let
me just throw it to this uh this this
year from tim cast real quick to go and
uh at the context philadelphia to
reinstate mass mandate for indoor public
places now i don't want to be as bold as
to say that the lockdowns are going to
come back hard because that's what i
said last year at the end of last year i
said i think they're going to bring out
the lockdowns back why they got an
election to win and they're losing right
now and what can they do
well they need chaos right so i think
there's a political play however
luke rudkowski if we are changed said no
no
they're going to ease it up they've lost
this one it's bad for them it's hurting
them they're going to ease it up
and then in january into february they
started easing up the restrictions
started ending a lot of these mandates i
said you know what i guess i was wrong
they really are ending these things and
now people are shouting out alex jones
but what he what he said was they're
gonna ease the the restrictions
get everybody to calm down and then
they're gonna slam them back down on us
and then i'll give myself some credit by
saying aha
the the rat hope experiment we talked
about you know about that one no so they
put a rat in a vat full of water several
rats
and let them swim and they couldn't grip
on anything after 15 minutes the rats
gave up they drowned
then they take more rats put them in the
vat full of water the cylinder let them
swim right before they give up they pick
them up and put them down and dry them
off let them rest catch their breath
then pick them back up and put them back
in the water
the rats then swim for 60 hours
because they had hope that if they just
didn't give up they would make it
so based on what alex said
you know based on what luke said what i
said i'm like maybe what's gonna happen
is these restrictions being lifted in
the calm down period are so that people
can have a sense of hope that it will
eventually come to an end but maybe this
next lockdown is the lockdown that just
goes on for a while isn't that the
definition of a psyop
yeah that's the definition of a psyop
you're playing a style up on that rap
we're just the rats
you know but i think americans have
woken up to that and i think it is to
such a degree that it's now not
republicans or democrats it's just
americans period waking up to it going
these people are playing us in a psyop
right now
listen anybody that identifies i've
raised a lot of money over the years for
republicans i campaigned with
republicans
and in the past two or three years i
have witnessed heard
and learned
things about so many republicans that i
had supported
that blew my mind how much they were
betraying the people oh yeah that they
represent
and i i've i've gone out and told people
that are hardcore republicans or
whatever i go you if you're an american
you better not identify with either
party just being american you look for
what you think is best for your family
that's it don't rely on these people
anymore because they if i had to guess a
percentage i'm going to say 85 percent
of all politicians
are not worth the paper that they signed
when they got that office did you see
the uh governor of utah using his
pronouns and saying the tinks
no i didn't say and people are like
tanks yeah this is a republican and he's
just all on board i would not be
surprised if
if people don't go out and vote in their
primaries and we end up with just more
neocon establishment uniparty trash
give it give it a year to mitch
mcconnell will be like i'm mitch
mcconnell he him and i'm here to give a
statement about taxes and that's it
unless people actually vote in the
primaries and get rid of these these
establishment party players you know
if we don't let them force you to put a
mask on your kid we won't be able to cut
taxes two percent for three years right
right
and then you'll have more money for your
kids while they're in school being
groomed
i basically stopped voting political
parties when i was like 15 or 16. it
didn't make any sense anymore i was like
why don't i just pick the best person so
that's what i do now well how do you
know who's a good person anymore i mean
here's a question who can you believe
anymore andrew yang that was not oh no i
mean he wasn't lying yeah he he goes on
cnn he gets a cnn contract after
everything oh maybe he got bought out i
i i like the idea of the ford party i
donated to them that's fine but uh that
guy lost a substantial amount of trust
when he went establishment and then then
he walked away a little bit after but he
was talking about economics so he's
talking about real pro felt like he was
talking about real problems sometimes
people like kelsey gabbard gets to the
heart of the issue i mean she's a little
bit too hawkish on war for me um you
mean she is thy war
no actually i think she's a little too i
mean she's in the military she comes
from the military he's bad in the
democratic party on the military issue
but i agree with you she's not perfect
she's the one who keeps complaining
about americans entering war
like that's her whole schtick is
stopping yeah but she was also like
afraid of terrorists and i'm like i
don't want a freak in in that white
house that's talking about terrorism
anymore i'm tired of that yeah yeah
that's scion i mean ron paul talked
about mark and reprisal against tara
paul was pretty good just
so i think i think there are real there
are acts of real terror but you know the
whole 9 11 terrorism thing that got
shoved down my throat for 20 years i'm
fed up with so someone's saying like ron
paul you know we should go after the
terrorists and not have these regime
change wars i don't think is a pro-war
position
ron paul or rand paul because i think
ron paul's position was we just need to
pull out entirely and we shouldn't even
have foreign bases ron paul uh yes but
he also talked about how instead of
invading iraq and afghanistan we could
have issued letters of mark and reprisal
okay so we could specifically target
rogue groups instead of declaring war
and you know we didn't do that trying to
build a democracy in afghanistan all
that ridiculous but but you know anyway
to to to back to this story
i think even you know the democrat view
on this is apocalyptic
and so i'm wondering if one they'll use
lockdowns politically
or they just
lie down and republicans come in and
sweep things up yeah maybe they'll lock
down and then lift the lockdowns shortly
before the election cycle begins like
six months or something i am so done
with these stupid lockdowns
i'm so done with it well take a look at
this we all thought we were by the way
take a look at this story daily mail
proof that blue states did fail their
people during the pandemic harsh
lockdowns caused huge death rates ruined
kids education and destroyed business
bombshell research finally shows with
new york new jersey california and
illinois all receiving an f minus grade
are you telling me that um jb pritzker
of illinois's brilliant plan to give 300
dollars of federal coveted relief money
to black lives matter didn't make the
virus go away i'm i'm shocked isn't that
true i would i would have assumed no
because we learned that the black lives
matter protests reduced exactly exactly
so it made sense so if he gives that
money to blm he's specifically giving it
to groups that cannot spread covet
i don't know i i guess the world's
upside down none of it makes sense to me
where we end up man yeah maybe maybe i
don't know what do you think john you
well i mean you know if they lock
everybody down and the red state's
pushed back and the exercise or 10th
amendment go yeah we're not locking down
we're going to have the election as
planned and all the blue states are
locked down and nobody can get out and
go vote maybe that actually plays to the
other side it's interesting the
boomerang effect and some somewhat of
the whiplash coming back how do you lock
everybody down now knowing how much they
hate it and still win an election also
with people seeing the effects of the
lockdown this is part of why it was so
important for them to try to scapegoat
putin in russia
this is part of why they had to say the
inflation and the food shortages were
his fault it was the result of a foreign
adversary not the fact that they printed
trillions of dollars not the fact that
they shut the economy down for two years
because anyone who's really paying
attention knows that this is only going
to get a whole lot worse if we lock down
well so is there actually evidence that
they're saying they're thinking about
locking or shutting down because i've
seen masks i've seen masks i didn't if
there was i just was the first thing
they did in 2020
15 days to slow the spread 15 days of
what of like shutting down i don't know
businesses or something working from
home going home shutting down did they
do masks before they shut everything
down
they went back and forth on it yeah
right first there was no you don't need
them and then you did need them but like
i think the masks were first the masks i
understand but the shutting down man
that's that's the poison we cannot do
that to our economy no it's shut down
first i know because i was on spring
break with my kids when all that
happened i'm sitting there in florida
bama if you've never been there go to
flora bama guys the edge of florida
alabama oh it's the best the redneck
riviera that's the heart of it right
there but we were down there and i'm
watching the news and then we get the
email like through four days into spring
break that the schools are shut down
you're not going back to school and all
that started to happen all the
interviews i was doing concerts i was
doing
they they closed the door on you right
out of the gate and then the mass was
when they started letting you move
around but you got to have a mask or two
masks or whatever it was because i mean
the concert scene is everybody just went
bang it was just over well if you're
rich you don't gotta worry about any of
it
you need to get it well you want to wear
a mask out of playing you have to worry
about it in a different way like is is
the money that i have going to be
valuable if the economy gets annihilated
as a rich person that's yeah that
process right they diversify their
assets
rich people buy land and so
yeah they don't have to worry about it
but you have to worry about whether you
might own land on paper but if someone
an armed militia goes there and sits on
it then you're going to have to take an
arm militia to get them out of there and
that's going to cost you probably more
than the land is worth but so it's also
about other assets and other resources
but just having a substantial amount of
substantial amount of resources you
command
access and power depending on how you
transfer what you trade a diversified
you know portfolio or whatever you want
to call it wealth asset management for
these people buying land yeah in the
event that uh we do go
you know more riotous because a lack of
food yeah the property you own is
meaningless you got a piece of paper
says your name on it some dude kicks the
door and says mine now what are you
gonna do about it look how people were
riding before we had any food shortages
just because the media told them they
should be upset
yeah i think they were doing that
because they didn't like being locked
down the george floyd riots that thing
it was like there was an excuse to get
out of the house and party burning man
got canceled so let's do it on the
street in new york did they just cancel
e3
oh i don't know yeah i think e3 got
cancelled and and i'm wondering for what
reason but i i think we might see
lockdowns come again because i don't
know how else democrats can even try to
win i think if don't you think that the
lockdowns would be bad for them
politically how would that help them win
i don't understand yeah yeah i think i
think i think that would be bad but then
i think they would get universal mail in
voting and then in a completely
unrelated story i think then the
democrats will win interesting yeah
completely unrelated
i think you know there will be lockdowns
you have weird coincidences universal
mail in voting and then uh what happens
is uh just oh totally as an aside other
story i think democrats win
interest just in general in life uh they
win yeah e3 was canceled i think you
know why it was canceled oh i didn't
know yeah yeah so i'm wondering if it's
covet or if it's just someone something
else says it was years in the making
you're seeing that e3 is that big video
game conference and the announcement was
canceled so i see that and i'm like well
what just happened but you know i
haven't i haven't been hyper focused on
that because the world's falling apart
you know how it goes
do you think do you think strong states
that are that are con led by
conservatives would push back now that
they know what they've known and you've
got stories like that about what a
failed and f minus yeah that they would
go no we know it didn't work we're not
doing it but then what civil war
the red states tell joe biden to shove
off we're not listening the the
let's say the democrats somehow managed
to pull a win despite all of the
evidence suggesting they'll lose and
then with senate and the house and the
presidency they start you know they go
for universal nationwide restrictions or
something like that
yeah the red states might say no but but
but then what well i mean you've still
got 10th amendment
right you know the living laboratories
of america it's one of my favorite
phrases where each state can do it their
own way i mean you've seen desantis do
it over and over it's flexing his
muscles
down there going now we're not doing
that and he just doesn't do it and the
government goes well then we're not
going to send you any money he goes i
don't need any money we have a surplus
of eighteen billion dollars there's no
need your money this is what we saw in
the first lockdown when joe biden was
coming out giving these speeches
it was obvious he wasn't talking to red
states he would say you know to america
we got to do these things and i'm like
the red states are doing none of those
things so he's only addressing blue
states at this point
i don't i don't know what ends up
happening in terms of this country
eroding and falling apart i certainly
think we're there i was thinking about
this
i think we were driving somewhere
recently we were out here in nashville
were driving around and i just i think i
was saying something to you about how
the left can be told
that joe biden sniffs little girls and
posts videos on it and they'll say i
don't care i want you to hurt
so they'll vote for joe biden despite
the fact that he's got a garbage career
he's been the press has read about his
corruption over and over and over again
they'll say i don't care i want you to
lose it's like you're voting for a guy
who's this i don't care trump's gross
too and it's like
it's like that kid that flips the table
when he's losing a game of monopoly i
once saw a kid right playing pokemon at
a tournament hit another kid with a
razor scooter wow that's that's what
it's like that's what it's like
you hear the rain yeah that rain got
intense uh e3 was canceled in in the
physical form because of covid according
to them and then they canceled the
actual event all around and they said
they're prepping for 2023 they're going
to do it again so they shut down e3
because of covet before any lockdowns or
masks or what why
it's no no no no
no it's a complicated question with a
lengthy answer and i'm like oh god do i
really want to do this that's a long
article it means you're about to get
light impact it's still talking about
covet halfway down the page it's
probably covered so fear coveted you
know
so john yes sir you're you're this uh
you know you mentioned you told us the
story about being at this party with
nancy pelosi
i'm i'm just wondering you're here
you're speaking out you seem rather
fearless on these issues but
are there ramifications
to being in mainstream us entertainment
and challenging the establishment smack
talking them
as we say in the country does a bare
[ __ ] in the woods right
that's a big west virginia saying as
well yeah
yeah you know what happened with me was
is i was becoming that guy that would
yell at the tv
but then i would go out at the industry
events a red carpet and interview
whatever
and understand that the majority of
people running our industry were
absolutely hated people that thought
like i think
and so i would just shut my mouth bite
your tongue don't say it in here and
just go back home and yell at the tv
again and at some point i felt like i
was i was sacrificing my integrity
sacrifice sacrificing my freedom of
speech why do we have these things
because hundreds of thousands of
americans have died and bled and
sacrificed and did whatever it took to
keep those freedoms alive that's why the
lines are coming into the country and
there's no lines going out because we
have those freedoms and i'm gonna sit
here and not say what's on my mind and
speak what i know to be true because i'm
afraid somebody's not gonna give me an
award or somebody's not gonna play my
song at the radio station or whatever
yeah that's the penalty but which one is
bigger the founding fathers are walking
out there going hey give me liberty or
give me death that was not a bumper
sticker that was not a hashtag that's
what it took to get this country up and
running and if they ever found those
guys that signed the declaration of
independence they ever found them
they're going to hang them from a tree
burn their houses kill their families
and erase them from the memory of the
earth but now we're worried about
somebody throwing us off of twitter or
somebody calling us a bad name or in my
case the the music industry not giving
me everything that i want to get out of
it at some point make a call decide
what's actually important to you is your
freedom of speech more valuable to you
than the approval of the music industry
that's where i got to go
got two little boys growing up and
they're watching me
and what if i'm dealing with this what
are they going to be looking at in about
15 or 20 years so i'm the only example
they have what did pop do when he ran
into that when the government did this
or tech did that or businesses did this
what did dad do did he just yell at the
tv and then go play ball or did he
actually say what he felt was he the
same guy all the time 24 7. did he take
his hits hell yeah and he got scars and
lost money and lost lost popularity with
a lot of people but what did he gain
self-respect integrity and he sleeps
okay at night not like dad good for you
that's why i do it like that so here so
here's my question for you
tremendous respect for all of that do
you fear
you know they'll try to come after your
kids or you might put your kids at harm
they better fear ever coming after my
kids
i love it because i'll let you i'll let
you get a very good answer i'll let you
i'll let you come after me all you want
to you you leave my family alone we will
die for our families
we'll die we'll we if you said john you
were them snap your fingers and take me
out of here i mean right now we as my
daddy would say who's a quasi
pentecostal style prison preacher that i
would charge hell wearing my gasoline
suit with my water pistol blazing if you
ever jack with my family and that's what
they don't understand in this country
these liberals and people running our
country that there there is a fierce
love and dedication and responsibility
that we have as parents that you step
over that line and you start messing
with my kids there is no there is no
boundaries anymore between us you want
full contact support you want to raise
the stakes on what you're doing to our
kids and how you're in my opinion
assaulting them in all these ways you're
going to assault my kids once you try to
assault me one time i'm going to step in
front of these little kids now you're
going to deal with it with a grown-ass
man and a grown-ass woman who got
nothing to lose and don't care what you
have to think about it this is where
america is going whatever look i have in
my eye right now because i know because
i know what i'm saying i'm feeling it
down in my guts that is what tens of
millions if not more americans are
feeling right now regardless of their
politics regardless of who they voted
for or what they think about trump or
biden you mess with our kids you've got
a world of hurt coming your way this
fall they're messing with kids good for
you man you've got you know these these
these teachers now bragging on social
media about how they want to talk about
their sex lives with children
and this it's the weirdest thing to me
that they're trying to normalize the
idea that five six seven and eight year
olds
are talking to the pa to their teachers
about their teachers marriages or
relationships
that never happened for me when i was in
those grades because florida is where
the big conversation started the
principal writes an education bill uh
when i was five i remember the names of
all my teachers actually i don't
remember the name of my second grade
teacher i'm sure some of my family does
but i remember these teachers i had no
idea who they were married to they had
no idea what they were doing i was five
i was eight i was nine
when i was 12 or 13
i learned about my teacher got married
that's all i learned she was out one day
a substitute came in why oh she got
married oh
they didn't come into the classroom and
say i want to tell you all about my
relationship with my husband and our
honeymoon never happened yet now this is
what they're saying oh but it's totally
normal i need to explain to these kids
like what it means
well you don't i mean first of all the
parents can
and this can be handled during normal
sex at ed if the parents think that's
what the school should be doing but
they're actually arguing for the right
to have conversations with your kids
about sexual issues in secret telling
those kids don't tell your parents
so this is happening are you
homeschooling
no do you want my kid no because i found
a school that won't put up with it
and so that's where my kids go but let's
just take that conversation out of the
classroom shall we let's go to a public
park and your kids are playing over by
the monkey bars and a couple of adults
walk up and start showing them those
books with those pictures and having
that conversation with them what would
happen to those adults
they would be arrested arrested and
hauled off to jail so if you look on the
american bar association when it goes
into uh the word grooming which is the
big word right now which is accurate in
my opinion it says and seventh circuit
court of appeals actually actually has
this perfect please go look it up
that um
it is not a defense to say that you are
uh putting explicit pornographic or
obscene material in front of a child
under the guise of education it is it is
already been stated it has already been
solidified you do not get to hide behind
the veil of education and that shields
you from something that outside the
school would be considered a felony
well this doesn't work that way but so
this game they're playing the only way
you short circuit that is at some point
parents are going to have enough of it
they're going to go you know what did
you show this to my kid all right turn
around put your hands back let's take it
to uh the workplace i think it was
robbie starbuck who tweeted this
if you if you talk to another co-worker
about what these teachers are talking
about you would be sued for sexual
harassment yeah that's absolutely right
down right i mean because
these books some of them have shown
relatively graphic images i wouldn't
they're like descriptive
instructional doctorals
if you went to the workplace take a look
at this book
they'd be like okay i'm going to the
boss the boss is going to be like i'm
letting you go
why are you showing these images but in
the school to children they're arguing
it's okay
under the guise of education what i'm
telling you is that's already been
established there's people who've
already tried to use that defense in the
highest courts in our land and they were
not upheld well people need to go after
these teachers and file suits file
charges whatever they have to do
absolutely on top of that another thing
that people are failing to acknowledge
here is that one of the core elements of
grooming is trying to separate the child
from their parents so by definition
having secret conversations with
children especially secret conversations
about sexuality is grooming and i think
everything you just said a moment ago
was put very beautifully and so many
people in this country feel that way and
i think the left is going to start to
realize that they've really woken asleep
and sleeping giant because they're
completely incapable of understanding
other perspectives all they know and
understand is obedience to the party
line and loyalty
to
their sick set of principles and what
their ideological allies tell them to
believe
i think many of them don't have close
familial relationships which is part of
why statistically they actually are more
likely to experience mental health
issues and so they can't comprehend the
bonds that exist between good and
healthy families they have no idea
what's coming their way if they continue
to push on this well i think
if if you go back in time we were
talking about several hundred years ago
where the dad's armed maybe he's got a
single shot you know flintlock or
something like that or a sword or a
knife or something because you never
know you gotta defend yourself your
friends your family
people without families were much less
likely to survive
that's just humans are social beings our
families and our tribes are how we
survived and that's why we have such a
strong social desire to be a part of
this the culture and the tribe because
if you weren't you didn't you didn't
survive
we now have an expanding
society of family-less individuals
they have some friends they hang out
they're in their 30s they're not
relationships they they're they're
single they live in apartments
i i i gotta say i don't think people
these people would survive the actual
wilderness they're they're a product of
the good times we've created the
security and the safety that allows this
individual ultra individualist
you know i guess lifestyle probably also
bunch of drug addicts on adderall prozac
who knows legalize pharmaceuticals so
they're like distorted and aren't able
to understand love with their mother you
know it comes from like well i didn't
get along with her to begin with and
like come on guys i'm just assuming a
type of person but there's a lot of
legalized drugs out there that people
are on well i mean also statistically we
know that children that come from two
parent homes fare better than children
who don't they have absolutely destroyed
and gutted the family it's been
a very long-standing project on the left
because they can't have competing power
structures and they know that good
tightly knit families that genuinely
love and care for each other and have a
strong sense of loyalty and parents who
will legitimately protect their children
solve the problems that the state claims
it needs to be in a position to solve
though it never solves them well it
usually ends up creating more problems
than it's addressing
but the point is they're not going to
stop right like they see your connection
to your family as a threat like it is a
threat to their way of life and what
they view is what's necessary for their
survival they're not gonna sound like we
have to stop them is the point they're
not gonna stop themselves let me give
you guys a white pill i don't know that
that's that's the optimism right the the
for sure the one that means things are
not so bad black pill is the end of the
white all right let me let me let me
tell you guys what i think is coming
i think the future is going to be
more conservative
than uh this country's been in maybe
like 70 or 80 years for one simple
reason
it has nothing to do with people waking
up to politics it has nothing to do with
young people being based
it has everything to do with the fact
that the left does not have children
and if they do get pregnant they are
substantially more likely to abort their
children kill their baby
so
back in uh the early 2000s conservatives
were having about two kids for every two
parents so they were st it was it was
stable
liberals were having 1.7 kids so
typically a family would have one kid
maybe two
now we see in the polls
that
gen z is a tad bit more conservative
than millennials but millennials and gen
z are still relatively progressive
compared to gen x's and boomers
what happens in 20 years from today the
birth rates collapsed
but conservatives still have a lot of
kids maybe less on average than before
but way more than liberals
if liberals if the left can't
indoctrinate children in schools
they cease to exist within maybe 40
years exactly it's necessary for their
survival you know what happened when the
immigration when the roman empire failed
and all the slaves were basically
when the roman slave system ended a
bunch of those people went out to the
farms and started working for the
farmers and became their workers uh it's
more nuanced than that and i would
highly recommend um looking into this
because if this hap if this really if
the economy fails and all these people
come out of the cities these liberal
weirdos that don't have families or
whatever they're going to be looking for
work and they're going to be basically
put down but even put on the farm to get
to work and they're going to be overseen
and then they're going to be you pay
whatever you want at that point do you
think they're aware enough to use on a
farm well no no no no i gotta disagree
bro like
there's a lot of people in cities who
could come and do basic farm work but
i tell this story all the time
let me ask you john uh you remember
occupy wall street i imagine sure
directed by wall street a bunch of land
was granted farmland was granted to
occupy wall street and so a large a
bunch of these these young people were
like i want to get off the grid i want
to be responsible for myself sustainable
and not be a part of the you know carbon
dioxide
corporate fossil fuel economy so they
went to this farm to be totally off the
grid sustainable how long do you think
my friend made it
uh i would say
halfway through his first callous
wherever that came from
halfway like my fingers
went through his first blister two weeks
that's about that's about that's your
first trick blister so i asked my friend
two weeks later you're back and they
said it sucked i woke up at 6 00 a.m and
i worked until 11 p.m yeah i never had
time to do anything it was just work
work work if you want to eat you got to
work then you had breakfast and you
worked again then you had lunch and you
worked again you had dinner and i was
like that's what survival sounds like
right yeah yeah yo these people yeah but
when the owner of the house has rifles
and you're in a fenced in area and
there's nowhere to get out and you you
chose to be there because you need food
like i'm saying we might be on track to
see another serfdom rise in this country
look you're you're you're not going to
be able to take entitled gaunt
millennials i'm not saying everybody's
going to make it either that's a good
point then because some there's a lot of
people in the states of course they're
capable you know i i i don't think
they're as skilled or as learned as
people in the countryside when it comes
to basic country things like the things
i've learned just you know moving out of
the cities over the past several years
it's like oh wow i didn't know that we
got chives growing in the backyard
everywhere you just walk up you pick
them you rinse them off you eat them i'm
like i don't even know what you can or
can't eat but the people out here are
like oh here's what you can't eat here's
what you can eat they can just tell me
right away so if if one day the roads
just
the roads were gone and it was like
you're only gonna get food which you can
find
they'd make it i'd be in serious trouble
so people in cities there's a lot of
smart people in cities but they're not
going to know the first thing about how
you you grow crops you know what we did
last year
you know those tomatoes we planted yeah
we planted all the tomatoes at once
and then what happened i'm sad you get a
lot of tomatoes and then you run out of
tomatoes yeah we have like 80 tomatoes
you can go and they get run exactly do
you know how to can
no oh you got to learn how to equipment
but we we do present man we can run out
of cases this is going to be our party
while we're out here you're just going
to keep stuff
we make preserves that's good i got
multiple very similar it's very similar
to that you just put tomatoes in it next
time there you go or potatoes or
whatever but i wanted to see your white
pill and and uh advance you one pill
because there's something i have i think
i've had a realization about about what
the future looks like when it comes to
the conservative population
all these kids
who were forced to wear mass eight hours
a day
day after day after day after day and
hated every second of it and they saw
their mother lose her job because she
wouldn't take the vaccination they saw
their daddy lose his job because he
wouldn't do x y z that the government
man was telling them to do and watch
their lives get destroyed
and watch their their their own person
be violated
over and over and over year after day
after day year after year now i believe
that they grow up and when they become a
voting age they remember
what that was and they go they're not
doing that to my kids i'm not voting for
anybody that would i ever think would
have a shred of a chance of ever
pressing down on us that hard again i
will never vote for them it doesn't
matter how liberal they might be or
whatever they go yeah i'm not voting for
that because this has been a horrific
experience i mean when i got two little
boys you see them little boys putting
masks on their faces see they see it
going in and out and in and out you go
to a basketball game and they're making
kids wear masks running up and down a
basketball court
child abuse is what that is and that
jacks with their brains i told my boys
you're not wearing a mask to school
anymore all the school said we had to i
said i'm going to send the school a
letter
so you look up online and you go is a
mass considered a uh is it considered an
experimental medical device
yes it is per the fda a mask is
considered an experimental medical
device when it comes to stopping the
contraction of a virus it is on their
website go look it up okay let's
extrapolate on that then do you have the
permission do you have the authority to
coerce me into using an experimental
medical device no you don't not if i
don't give you permission to well then i
don't give you permission to well you
have to do it anyway or we're going to
punish you oh you know what that's in
violation of nurnberg code i think it is
go read the exact language on that you
are not allowed to force people to do
something against their will anything
medically and if they don't do it punish
them for it and so i sent a little
letter
and spelled all that out and put the
links on there and highlighted what it
said right off the government websites
and guess what i got five minutes later
an opt-out form oh
interesting and opt-out for them they
didn't want to have that fight well
here's well they don't want to have
anything
here's the issue i see
i think there's a there's a rudimentary
um view on masks i think masks work but
it's it's simple if you're gonna cough
or spit on somebody the mask will stop
you from doing it but then there's
questions about forcing everybody even
people who aren't sick to be wearing one
you know we used to see all the time
people in asian countries if you get a
cold they put a mask on just so that
they don't cough or spit on somebody
that's simple i mean that's a basic
logic but then they come in and they say
five-year-olds who may or may not be
sick we don't care just they have to do
it and then there's serious questions
about okay well what are you doing to
the the develop development of their
mind if they can't see mouths move if
they can't see human expression while
they're communicating at one of the most
formative years of their lives
when these kids aren't even sick or not
only that but they're substantially less
likely to get sick i can certainly
understand if a parent wants to make a
choice for their kids that should be on
the parents not not the government and
this is why i just say the simple
solution really is getting your kids out
of these schools getting in pods but it
sounds like you found a solution which
was an opt-out form that they
well so i think it goes back to the
point that these these people are
generally bullies
whether it's talking about masking your
kid up or it's talking about grooming
them in a school room or whatever
they are not willing to go the full
distance of what that fight actually
looks like if we've got the backbone to
take it there they don't want to go that
far they don't want to go in a courtroom
and and have a and have a let's go back
to the school that's being taught in
schools hold up the book in front of a
jury read the state and federal statutes
as to what it says about exposing kids
to obscene material then show the jury
the pictures read the jury the book and
ask the jury are they guilty of
violating these statutes they're going
to go of course okay judge what's the
penalty for violating the statute you're
in big trouble why is that why why isn't
it happening though because people are
too afraid to stand up again and that is
the problem with getting too blackfilled
about this stuff your average person
goes around thinking i know that what
they're forcing on me is nonsense but i
can't make a difference but like you
said and like you were able to show in
the situation with your kids in this
school if you stand up to these people
it's not always going to work out for
you 100 of the time but you're never
going to know unless you try and the
problem is nobody's trying yeah it
sounds like the evidence that you
accrued that you sent to them would be
valuable to put public so that other
people could grab the evidence and send
it i have a high school diploma okay
i'm a self-taught i read myself i can
think on my own and i look at this and i
go that's got to be illegal to do that
surely that's illegal well let's just
look
and here you go and you can find volumes
of information as to yes your gut
instinct was correct your common sense
proves to be true again here's all the
ways that that's illegal and here's all
the case law to back it up and here's
what happens when somebody breaks that
you present that to the other side they
do not want to have that fight out in
the open i really appreciate what you
just said a moment ago like i have a
high school diploma there are so many
people who are so overeducated and then
they can't even think to do the simplest
possible thing when it comes to
protecting their own children yeah it's
an indoctrination camp that's a big part
of why public schooling and the college
industry they want you to sit down wait
till you're called on i mean tim dropped
out you got out of high school basically
and then what was your you went to
college you went to an art class i did
yeah i know can you believe it what were
you did you do college lydia no i didn't
you were like homeschooled too for a
long time yeah so i actually started to
take crap uh classes that were the um
equivalent of prereqs for nursing
because i really like biology and that
kind of thing so there was no doctrine
indoctrination there they're just like
here's what's up this is what's really
happening i was wildly
indoctrinated yeah i have to break that
mold every day yeah i'm just ready to
say yes and and follow the leader but i
i'm it's not what i want so that's not
to fight against it
it's funny because i went to catholic
school from kindergarten until the end
of fifth grade and i wouldn't even call
any of that indoctrinating like they
didn't even do a good job teaching me
about christianity of course not it was
catholics
they teach you how to learn which is sit
raise your hand don't speak unless
you're called on which first of all is
like are you kidding that's that's a
stomps on creativity you need to let
kids express themselves and be their
best self
and there's other ways you know wait and
you can only go out you can't leave the
classroom unless you're allowed to go
for it maybe maybe that's the part of
the drift right so even in a catholic
school
we see them now many of these churches
putting up blm flags yeah exactly stuff
so when i'm a kid
we had religion class you could take out
your religion book at 9 a.m or whatever
and they wouldn't really actually teach
us about the the the complex ideas
around spirituality faith in the
universe it was kind of just like read
the paragraph
i'll be reading my book again we learned
i'll be collecting my salary at the end
of the week imagine if catholic schools
were as interested in teaching the
students about catholicism as public
schools are at teaching kids to become
transgender i say this to people as a
catholic if someone has a deep love for
jesus christ and the blessed virgin and
my faith you can't assume that a
catholic school is going to be good for
your kid in most instances in most
instances it won't be i'm a big advocate
of homeschooling uh probably because
i've never done it being facetious i'm
sure it's it's easy for someone who
doesn't have kids but also i know i'm a
huge advocate of homeschooling i think
these institutions are are terrible
there are some really good institutions
you can still find
but for the most part you can't say oh
well it's like it's a catholic school
therefore they're going to teach my kids
good things absolutely
so i i grew up in chicago with a fairly
liberal family but my mom still wanted
to homeschool me and my siblings and
then once i went to i went to catholic
school kindergarten to fifth grade then
public school sixth to eighth i spent a
couple months freshman year of high
school and my my parents pulled me out
saying it was bad went back to
homeschooling we did a correspondence
thing where my dad would come in you
know every day and then these are my
parents working my parents were getting
divorced but my dad would come in like
what did you read about what did you
learn ask me questions let's talk about
it we ended up i ended up me and my
brother sped through the entirety of
high school because we could go as fast
as we wanted
and i look at the school system as just
corrupt for a lot of reasons outside of
what they're doing now with the the
creepy conversations with with these
children and they're like we have to
talk about our relationships and our
significant others and i'm like to
five-year-olds that sounds really weird
you know but it's also just really bad
they don't do a good job of actually
teaching kids
if
i i'm i'm i believe
that every human has potential
that if you take a kid from anywhere and
you give them access to knowledge and
you teach them and you show them here's
how you hammer a nail here's here's how
you you know build a bicycle they're
gonna learn that i still remember the
cheat code from teenage mutant ninja
turtles 2 on nintendo b-a-b-a up down
b-a left-right b-a stark why do i
remember that because that game was
awesome 36. i played that game for like
a few months of my life and i'll never
forget the code for level select in that
game it's crazy i got 007 373 5963 is
the password to get to mike tyson and
mike tyson
now what if as kids what if as kids
instead of learning that stuff we were
taught something
like language for instance yeah multiple
languages how about what happens when
you go to a school and you got a kid
who's ready to learn and absorb
information and they just waste their
time
they talk about nonsense and politics
these kids are going to grow up without
critical thinking skills and not just
waste their time but groom them yeah and
then on top of that like well let's say
let's say we had public schools which
functioned effectively and were really
teaching kids the things they needed to
be taught the idea that you're going to
sit a kid in a desk for six hours a day
and end up having any kind of productive
outcome from that is insane yeah they
make the smart kids wait like you i used
to stare at the clock and just wait to
be done because i was like what are you
doing um i want to talk about grooming a
little bit because it doesn't have to be
firstly i don't think it has to be
sexual you can groom someone to be a
psychopath to do other bad things and it
doesn't have to be non-parents i think
parents can groom their kids to do evil
things if they're bad people
yeah here's the fascinating thing is
there's this big like the big push now
from the left is they're saying
uh
parents are are grooming kids into
heterosexuality by talking about like
marriage and things like that
and i was like okay let me let me just
make this clear uh the parental rights
and education bill prevents
a teacher from talking to a
five-year-old about traditional marriage
i mean the bill does that and then you
can't encourage the kid to keep it a
secret
so no that's that's a ridiculous
argument it's not happening the reality
is people just like hey i don't want you
talking to my kids about adult content
about adult issues also for you to
decide one thing that we just have to be
able to acknowledge is if you think
that's even remotely true your brain
just doesn't work properly telling a
child that they can someday grow up and
get married and have a family is
absolutely not equivalent to trying to
encourage them to engage in sexually
depraved behaviors when they're older or
render themselves
experimental hormones but i'm not even
saying i'm not even going that far i'm
taking their position on this where it's
like a guy says
my kids might ask me you know my
students might ask me about having a
boyfriend and it's like yeah that's not
banned you can literally be like yes
it's a photo of my boyfriend now if you
want to understand this but you're a boy
too well maybe you should talk to your
parents and and and they can help you
understand the
these more adult concepts and the kid
will say okay and that's it and said
they're like let me tell you about all
of it that that's that's not if the
kid's confused or doesn't understand
because not exposed to it you just
simply say maybe it's something your
parents should talk to you about you
know i'm not here to teach you about
that stuff but um you know
it's the guys of education that's all
this is right they are hiding behind the
guys
and the excuse of and the shield of they
think education if you take the same
exact situation same exact scenario same
exact people and you put them out in the
public park or you put them at a mall or
you put them over at somebody's house or
whatever and the same exact thing went
down you would have the right to go
after those people i feel like the the
politicians are wrecking the economy as
under the guise of politics right yeah
they're just a bunch of people that have
done a really horrible horrible thing to
us in the last couple of years i think i
think nancy pelosi joe biden mitch
mcconnell uh they're just they're just
they should have retired a long time
passively letting the federal reserve
annihilate our economy it's not no no i
i get that but what i'm saying in
addition to this other stuff i mean look
at what age do you retire from baseball
you you guys 38 40 41.
if there's one thing we've learned to
the left age is just
yeah there's still you guys remember
true
a
number
when i think it i think it was snapchat
had a sticker that said age love has no
age disgusting yeah yeah and then it got
pulled people were like what does that
mean i do believe their solar age is how
many times your body's been around the
sun but then there's your genetic age
and and some people age
faster and slower depending on how much
damage you're doing to your telomeres my
my point is just simply
in any other industry
all of these people would have retired
not every single one but like pelosi
uh dianne feinstein joe biden come on
you know it's about time they should
have retired 20 30 years why do they
have power i don't understand i mean
it's the system it's the system we built
that our ancestors built that we can
vote a popularity contest to put someone
in forever it's it's the apathy of the
people
we we are too comfortable everything is
too good so people just stopped paying
attention the left stopped paying
attention the democrats not paying
attention and then the woke nonsense
came in and they just adopted and said
fine we'll use it the right stopped
paying attention and they let the
cultural institutions get taken over by
what left insanity and here we are that
now that's a tidal wave that's coming
though is on the local level i can tell
you right here in middle tennessee every
single county in middle tennessee
has parents and grandparents who are
running for school board positions
county commissioners you name it all the
way up and down the tickets and they
these guys are running for the hills
they don't know what to do because the
parents are so fired up that that the
schools won't listen to them
uh and are just running roughshod over
their rights as parents they're just
going well i'm a stay-at-home mom but
i'm running for the school board my
name's sally vote for me and they're
like i'll vote for you sally no problem
i'm telling you this is happening all
over the u.s
they're going to they're going to turn
these little these little local
situations upside down and i don't think
they'll ever get their power back
because we we have been asleep we've
been asleep a long time we just assumed
that we just assumed that uh you know
there got to be good people because
they're on the school board they care
about kids right that that seems like an
easy thing to do yeah but that's not
true they had another agenda as to why
they wanted to be on the school board
and now we're all learning that and so
regular old people are standing up and
flipping it around i'd love to be on my
kids school board absolutely when your
kids like you and they see you at school
it improves their mood and then they
become more popular and well liked at
school that's your dad that's awesome
man you know you know what works for uh
uh
tim casts of our company i i encourage
people
and within reason to bring their kids
into work when they can uh i want i want
their kids to see what work looks like i
want them to interact with adults i
think you should treat kids like adults
within reason obviously you treat it you
can cuss in an adult you can get an
argument with them you can show them
certain things you wouldn't show a kid
but you talked to them on on
on matters age relevant as you if you
were as if they were adults
so if they say hey what is this
if ian said you know how do i how do i
fix the mic i'll be like okay take the
xlr plug it that's the cable right there
i would i wouldn't say to the kid okay
this is a microphone a microphone no no
i just talk to them like normal so they
can learn
i like it when the kids can come in
first of all it's fun
we've got skee ball we've got a skate
park and i want them to be like this is
exciting i want kids to look up to
success and say if i work hard and and
and i believe in myself i can accomplish
cool stuff too i can be respected i can
have fun and i want them to see real
working adults interact with each other
here's trade here's money being
exchanged here's i need this job done
here's how you help chickens here's how
you clean the floors so that's what i
really like
i think that's infinitely more valuable
than what schools do
my family owned a business when i was a
kid and that's what i saw
i i saw adults talking about politics
they talked to me they didn't care that
i was a kid and they'd be like i just i
got to learn from real people real you
know i can tell you some of the stuff i
tell my boys
uh is
you want to play baseball i want to play
baseball i want to be in the mlb 10
years old
i go all right he goes and there's this
bad it's called a marucci bat that's
like the best bat you could possibly get
he's not on the team yet i said
i'll tell you what i'll get you that
marucci bat you go pick out the best
glove that you want and that's it i
can't get you on the team and i cannot
hit a home run for you and i cannot
catch a flat ball for you you got to go
out in the backyard and take 100 swings
a day on that thing off that tee you got
to get on the team i can't if you don't
make the team that'll be terrible you
know i'd hate it for you but that's how
this goes so here's the best bat here's
the best glove go make it yeah my dad
did that too he got me the martin
dreadnought he gave when i was like
wanting to learn towards like if you're
going to learn a trade get the best tool
you can for it and that you learn it
with that yep but it's on you to go do
it and there's no lying you're not going
to walk up to the coach and be like i'm
the best player you've ever seen and
he'll be like you're on the team then no
he's going to be like prove it yeah and
you can only you can only prove it by
doing it yeah when the kid strikes out
at the game you go well how many how
many swings did you take on the t this
this week in the backyard
none he was on your ipad the whole time
right yes what sucks striking out from
all your friends doesn't it
yeah i go well if you don't want to feel
like that again maybe i'll go out there
and swing it but that's on you i don't
care if you're in mlb or not i just want
you to be good at whatever you do you're
gonna be good at baseball go hit go
swing baseball bats and so he goes okay
and so little you're right about kids
people underestimate kids like they
don't understand it they understand
better than most adults because their
mind's not cluttered up with all this
nonsense that we all have it's very
clear to them what you're saying you
should you should treat them with
respect when you talk to them all right
let's go to super chats if you have not
already smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show click the
share button if you really do like it
head over to timcast.com we're gonna
have that members only show coming up
around 11 or so p.m eastern time so you
don't want to miss that and i'm saying
eastern time because we're in central
time right now so just so everybody
knows but a lot of people are often like
what time zone are you in we're
currently in central but it'll be 11 p.m
eastern let's read some of these super
chats
we got
paul fongham says you guys should have
people from china uncensored on again to
talk about shanghai and their zero
coveted policy that would be amazing
we'll definitely look into that
shock the casbah says hey john i've
played your club in nashville even saw
your bus i've given the cabinets a
thumbs up i give the cabinet a thumbs up
thank you brother
what's the club
redneck riviera downtown at third and
broadway i gotta go it's got a it's got
an american flag and a gaston flag
flying right over the top all right if
you're if you're a vet or or active duty
or a first responder first drinks on the
house we've given away probably ten
thousand cocktails so far wow come come
see my bar when you're in town so cool
that's cool all right murph tri says i
let my kids watch chicken city on
saturday today my two-year-old would
crow like a rooster then from the other
side of my house my five-year-old would
gel chicken party
here's the great work you guys hear the
next hit piece like is tim paul is sir
timothy cass turning children into
chicken wannabes with his programming
i've gotten some is it a bad influence
some far left activist is like posting
screenshots from our vlog channel which
is like
skateboarding rollerblading um
enhancement interrogation techniques you
know usually it's like making cake
making getting a cake for ian's birthday
and they're like look at the fart right
look what look at this the people
supporting them and it's like a guy
playing guitar and singing it's like
someone's singing kumbaya and i'm like
yo you've lost it exactly well and i'm
gonna say something that if they were
ever gonna act on would be like you know
bad for us but they're too stupid too
it's actually really good for us that
they're doing that because the whole
point of the vlog is we're just trying
to show people you can
have fun build culture etc while still
being conservative or at the very least
not on the left and so for them to try
to make it sound like it's scary that
we're doing everyday normal things is
just going to make us seem more normal
and likeable it feels like people are
throwing pebbles at a rocket ship as
it's taking off and it's like you know
throw as many as you want but but but
also you look like a lunatic when you do
that yeah and like history will show
that so stay strong and keep going i can
only imagine the advertisers are getting
these emails from people like look at
what you're supporting and it's like
someone playing a guitar for chickens
and they're like i really don't
understand how this is bothering anybody
all right high fiving tipping really
well when we go out there they just show
them tim's ad friendly chicken shell
yeah like look at this jackads all right
uh why and it's chickencitylive.com now
that's right oh great and um it is uh
so it's only it's all we've only been
hitting good super chats for the past a
week but at the current rate it will be
one of the highest grossing super chat
shows in the world
because of how just ridiculous people
are just throwing money at the chickens
they love it
the interactive uh super chat thing is
incredible you give five bucks treats
come down the chickens all run to get it
what is it it builds up to a hundred
dollars and then then the sky egg
releases the goods
we we increase the duration of the
parties they're over a minute now i'm
sorry and the chickens go nuts and yeah
they come running when they hear the
music i have a chicken song seriously
it's called i play chicken with the
train cowboy troy right yeah look up
cowboy troy i play chicken with the
train
rich can you want a real slam and
country rock rock and rap song for your
chickens i'm just saying it would be an
honor
the next plan was we're going to create
a shuffle mix so every chicken party is
a different song and i was like we need
to wrap one we could do country wrap we
could absolutely rock we got dance you
got to use that i don't know cleaning
chicken party intro to all of them
chickens end up having too many parties
they're just going to become depressed
are they going to get they're not going
to be able to survive yeah
good times create weak
chicks so you know
we we don't give them that much treats
only maybe like i think like 10
mealworms fall out at a time
and there's
what 14 chickens so they all rush to get
them
but i gotta be honest the chicken
parties there might be like 30 or 40
that come out and people keep doing it
so i'm like i know because they realize
the other actually raised the cost of
the chicken parties up because the more
people that come otherwise it's going to
be a chicken party 24 7. which i'm not
exactly well i got an idea i got an idea
then you have a chicken shower
chicken rehab show here's my idea
a drama reality show here's my rehab my
idea is right now we're using very
rudimentary code
but i would love to get dynamic code
where when the chicken meter fills all
the way up it doesn't just trigger
it starts at 100 and then counts down to
zero so the party goes on for the
duration of the meter which means while
the party is happening if you super chat
it'll bounce back up and keep partying
oh good idea so then people could keep
throwing money to keep the party going
keep the party going these people will
be like
all right let's read some more super
chats we got wyofet he says hey guys
question for mr rich does he have
another collab in the works with mike
rowe
oh cool great uh me and mike have been
talking about that actually and thanks
for adding we did a christmas song
called santa's got a dirty job oh yeah
because microsoft
jobs right
so uh i was hanging out with mike and i
said we got he's got this great voice
people don't realize mike rowe was uh
saying opera for like 12 years
oh he's a very talented
singer yeah yeah phenomenal singer so he
goes he goes that'd be great john you
should write a christmas song so i wrote
it and he came to nashville we recorded
it we put it out and this song i was
telling you uh before we went on the
song went number one on the sales chart
across all genres and knocked a dell out
of number one for eight days when her
new record had just come out so you know
they're sitting over there in london new
york going mike rowe and john rich
santa's got a dirty job that deals at
number two for eight days this is poor
adele this keeps happening remember the
article we were reading about how the
let's go brandon song knocked a doll out
of first place and this left-wing
journalist was super upset about it yeah
all right matthew hammond says i thought
country music was safe until i started i
started hearing some big acts coming out
for gun control after sandy hook how do
we keep these ideas out of our culture
boycotts
better ideas
there's a there's quite a there is quite
a void uh gulf
between the music industry the country
music industry and the country music
audience i mean massive and every now
and then you'll hear somebody poke up
and say something from the industry side
and the the fans go i don't think so
well that's only happened a couple of
times because they understand what the
backlash is like but in reality a lot of
the people on music row here in
nashville not all but many majority
they would be the ones that would call
those people out there listen to country
music the deplorables anybody that voted
for trump they
there have been major record producers
in nashville
that after the after trump was elected
the guy walks in he's got all these
musicians sitting in a room in a big
session he goes if anybody voted for
trump raise your hand two guys raised
their hand and he fired him on the spot
and kicked him out of the studio
i mean that's the culture now of music
row it's not the culture of a lot of the
artists but it is a culture of the
industry we'll take a look at uh you're
familiar with what happened with the
offspring and their drummer yes pete
perrotta oh yeah he's he's we got him he
got he's recording tracks with us good
and it is a it is a childhood dream come
true on the one where you said the high
who's singing the highs yeah that's
cheap on the drums yeah he's incredible
so uh i'm a kid playing offspring covers
and he's he's he was there i think i
think maybe their second drummer or
maybe third their third i think he's
third because they had an early drummer
who wasn't there for that long and uh he
plays with them for almost two decades
and then they disrespect him like that
that you know he he couldn't get
vaccinated because of uh guillain-barre
syndrome and then i we end up meeting
him he says yeah i'll definitely rule
some attraction to you now i get the
privilege the honor of getting to record
songs with this this you know he's so
good the way he slides across the head
of the drum i mean i don't know what
he's i mean musical outlaws were always
the ones who went against what the
government said to do
yeah how punk rock those were the actual
outlaws that said will you know i don't
think so and they would buck the system
now it's the other way where all the
tough guys out there the bruce
springsteens and so forth are out there
going you better do everything the
government tells you to do or you can't
come to my concert if you don't follow
it to the letter i'm like what happened
to outlaw musicians what happened to
them rambunctious punk rock hey take two
of these and call me in the morning
attitude from all of our american
artists where did that go it's almost
like now the conservative artists are
the new outlaws it's weird yeah that's
so crazy yeah all right dean sherwood
says long time watcher for super chat i
really enjoy the trailer shows please
ask john about the song 8th of november
heartbreaking love you guys at wefast
2019 coming back soon so what is 8th of
november 8th of november one of the
great things about country music is we
get to write songs about actual people
actual places actually events put them
into a song put them out and they
actually get played like it's real as a
heart attack so this song is about a
vietnam veteran big kenny and i met in
south dakota deadwood south dakota
outside of sturgis he was our bartender
this was before we had a record deal and
this guy tells us a story about a battle
november 8 1965 the first major ambush
of vietnam
uh all 30 got all 27 out of 30 guys were
killed except this one guy and two
others but they shot him up so bad that
he went to walter reed for two years
getting over his injuries he limped out
of walter reed and guess what this guy
does he signs up and does three more
tours of vietnam for the united states
army and then retires back in his home
state of south dakota and he's telling
us his story
and i said dude you're an actual legit
american hero yes he goes i ain't no
hero man the ones that didn't come back
are the real heroes so we wrote this on
the 8th of november we took him all the
way back to the we had former communist
vietnamese guys take us back up to
mekong delta and out into these fields
into a crater that was made by one of
our bombs right in the field where all
those guys got slaughtered took him down
in there had a shot of whiskey saying
the 8th of november it's on youtube if
you look at the 8th of november
documentary you'll find it but
that's what country music really is to
me that's why i make it because i can
experience something real and i don't
have to filter it i can just tell you
about this incredible guy or tell you
about this incredible situation and the
fans eat it up and they love it because
even though it's not their granddaddy
not their uncle it reminds them of the
people in their family that they love so
much wow great beautiful can i ask you
something yeah which country artist
inspired you the most
i think the greatest singer songwriter
that ever lived with johnny cash
i think and the reason i say that is
because he could say more
with fewer words than anybody that ever
put a pencil to the page
if you write out the lyrics to a johnny
cast song it'll take up a third of the
page and that's it that's the whole song
but it's a tidal wave and mount everest
of information and feeling that comes
out of that it's like in the way it
vibrates right here in his chest as it's
coming out and you can kind of hear the
the emotions in his in him he was so
effective in everything that he did and
so powerful and never duplicated one of
the problems i have with modern music as
i say it sounds like it went to the
school of redundancy school
you know yeah i get all i can i can just
interchange the artist and interchange
the
a lot of the songs but back in the day
you know you had real characters that
there's only one dolly parton do you
think it's auto-tuned right like
auto-tune that homogenizing industry or
maybe pharmaceutical culture that
homogenizes them it's what we've been
talking about this entire podcast that
this system this machine that's in place
is trying to break out any end of
individuality whatsoever break it down
flush it out get rid of it everybody's
got to think the same way do the same
thing and when that fight when those
kids grow up and start making music
that's kind of how they think
they don't really have the nerve to step
outside of the box and take chances all
right we got amanda who says today is my
daughter sophia's 7th birthday she
watches your show can you please wish
her a happy birthday happy birthday
sophia nice job sophia happy 7th
birthday congratulations
you did it right
dallas smith says ask john if he's still
friends with is that uh lilia stepanova
i was friends with her in high school
and she claimed to be close friends with
you she's the og barefoot bow
contortionist if so tell her i said hey
love your work by the way
i have not talked to her in a long time
but that's that's a
that's a pretty incredible person yeah
she can do
you meet so many people out on the road
i'm 48 i took off on the road at 18
years old wow i've been going been going
the whole time if there's a like i said
a town more than twenty thousand people
i've probably played at least twice did
you blossom music center you're a play
over there
akron blossom music center absolutely
yeah yeah yeah that's my home that's big
country music territory yeah
that's my blood all right wayne shannon
says check out thesurvivalpodcast.com
learn to live a better life if times get
tough or even if they don't i've been
listening to jack science uh or jack
since 2012 it's changed my life it says
science but i think when people do voice
to text things like that happen
all right
philip hughes says question for john are
you gonna take tim on a sightseeing tour
of nashville in your cadillac
convertible like you did ben shapiro
uh i watched it yesterday tim
maybe maybe
it's a 68 cadillac deville convertible
that is the slickest thing you've ever
seen i it would be my honor to put it's
got a giant back seat too put all you
fellas in that's beautiful take you
right down broadway hooping and
hollering pull right up in front of
redneck riviera and let's get you on
stage to jam a little bit with one of
the bands when can we do it saturday
you tell me when i know a guy that's got
a cadillac in a bar hey what's that
be happy to take you i'm totally down or
i also have a smoky in the bandit car
you might want that one whichever one
you think is the best uh we could we
could do saturday theoretically we could
do uh thursday or friday afternoon they
close at 11 though 11 00 p.m central
time what does i was looking at the
hours and i was like i'd really like to
go to this part well well my bar if if
we know we're going it does not close oh
that's of course there you go no no we
in the afternoon in between my morning
yeah or just saturday you know nashville
is a drinking town with a music problems
yeah yeah very aware of that before you
go downtown you know when uh we walked
around i think sunday through nashville
it is the greatest downtown i've ever
been to in my life yeah i love music
i've been playing music my whole life
new york is random there's different
neighborhood pockets and it's just you
got to find the place chicago it's all
business downtown there's art museums
and stuff like that los angeles doesn't
have it downtown when i come to
nashville and i'm like it's live music
you walk up to one one one bar
restaurant you can hear live music you
walk 10 feet totally different song
playing different artists and i'm like
this is amazing both sides of the street
both sides all the doors are open it's
stereo coming back and forth and listen
we open up at redneck river at about 9
30 in the morning we close at 2 30 at
night
and there are live music literally all
day long and into the night people come
here from all over the world to hear
that talent and the talent comes here
from all over the world they come here
from everywhere we got we got a girl
from england that's over here we got we
got a band from australia that moved to
nashville this planet my bar it's it's
an incredible place what is it what's
the capacity for the stage and
everything like how many people i've got
three floors i've got a rooftop bar so
it depends on which floor you're on
today i think
people might come if we do this on
saturday yeah let's do it let's do it i
think a lot of people don't hey like we
say in nashville don't threaten me with
a good time
i'll be i'll be that would be amazing
i'd love to play some songs i'm sure
yeah
rock and roll hang out james will you be
there i won't be there oh traveling for
easter that's right that's right i'll
scream your name out please
[Laughter]
i'll zoom in with my harmonica perfect
yes
all right let's grab some more busted
knuckles says i live in rio last census
was 250k i know my family will be okay
but the way amarillo is amarillo is it
amarillo amarillo
uh is i fear the city folk will destroy
if it goes bad people here won't take it
well we're already pissed off
oh man
all right let's let's try and grab some
more super chats cause we're having too
good of a time here
you guys rock out there yeah seriously
the cheaper shits are right in front of
me now with this setup i like it
grim reaper said here's another reason
to have a 30 plus mag boars travel in
packs hit one and doesn't fall uh off
the first time hit uh off the first hit
the will all charge and tear apart a
human you need every round to save your
life hunting you ever see that viral
tweet where the guy said 30 to 50 feral
hogs coming through my yard and all of
these you know gun control liberals
laughed at them and mocked them and then
all of a sudden articles pop up saying
actually yeah hogs are a serious problem
oh yeah they over populated millions
everywhere yeah they're terrible but
these people live in cities are like oh
thirty hogs and feral hogs will kill you
oh there you go oh yeah they're [ __ ]
dangerous as anything ever was
absolutely i heard regular farm pigs
will kill you they will yeah so i've
been told on farm like if you when you
walk into the pig pen they'll start
nipping at your heels and your legs and
you've got to like push them back with
those bores those boards got tusks just
like that you know pigs will eat each
other oh yeah they're i mean they are
man i just i just watched a pig crush
chicken bone yeah yes i i didn't know
that but you
give me a chicken bone it's like a
redneck hippopotamus yeah it really yeah
it is that's great oh that's awesome
no they're people don't realize they're
dangerous yeah yeah i mean dorothy fell
in the pig pen and the wizard of oz
remember and they all freaked out
because they knew the pigs are going to
enjoy that you know what it is there is
just a complete lack of respect for
nature
yeah that's true man yeah the terror
bird is one of the ones look at the
terror bird that thing used to exist
over here the terror bird it's like this
nine foot tall
vulture looking ostrich bird used to
hunt humans and we're going with extinct
animals man
i don't want to do it
why do you need a rocket launcher
tyrannosaurus rex that's right all right
andrew hobson says thanks for a horse of
a different color it made my childhood
and many road trips also tim has
radicalized me i thought i was pro 2a
because i wanted a select fire rifle but
after hearing you i would want a
military warship if i could afford it
dreams are free i guess
back in the day people had warships
and and cannons and cannons despite what
joe biden has said yeah he's like you
can't fight you can buy a cannon now you
couldn't buy a cannon
on the country man well the stupid thing
about that is antique firearms aren't
even considered legally regulated
firearms so flintlock pistols are just
they're not you're not going to be able
to do anything with it i mean you could
but
they're not regulated so yes you can
have cannons
can i give a piece of gun advice yeah
yeah so there's a thing called any gun
owners out there if you own a few guns
or whatever you got this thing called a
gun trust
and you can you can it's basically a
family trust you're the head of the
trust
think of it as an llc you can sign over
the ownership of all your weapons into
the family gun trust wow and if anybody
ever does come to you and says give me
all your guns you show them a piece of
paper and go i don't own any guns oh the
trust owns the guns i'll see you in a
courtroom that's right and then they got
to go they got to go pierce the the veil
of that llc to get down to you it's a
whole layer of protection it's a few
hundred dollars it's not crazy expensive
uh i would suggest if you have if you
have a any kind of collection of of
weapons at all think about getting a gun
trust well there are any drugs would
that give multiple uh ownership then yes
so your family members anybody if you're
you're the executor of it you can add on
your wife your kids your uncle whoever
so you know pass away they don't inherit
the guns they're just part of the trust
wow wow that's actually really that's
brilliant go look that up so there's
also questions about who has a right to
you know on your property use a weapon
and so what i'm told in some marriage
let's put this way the cops are like in
an emergency someone can take the weapon
but you know they're like but you you
someone shouldn't be bearing a weapon
they can't come in your house and take a
gun that doesn't belong to them for no
reason there's like rules and stuff i
suppose they they try to be more lacks
about it like the penguin state you're
in but there are some states that are
ridiculous and strict
so that's one way to you mean like you
mean somebody coming into your house and
taking one of your weapons like if if
you own a gun and then someone else who
is hanging out your house takes that and
starts using it
some states are very very strict on
your in possession of got it for someone
else in your home right right right
but you're talking about using it in
self self-defense not someone taking it
and self-defense so
i don't i don't trust these these states
the seven year states or whatever when
they're like oh no you're not supposed
people who don't own the gun aren't
allowed to use it because it's got you
you got to have a handgun license
but in self-defense it's fine i'm like
nah i don't trust you you're you're
you're not
yeah you might say that but am i going
to trust the the d.a or whatever
government official no if it's
self-defense defend yourself and let's
go hash it out down the road don't don't
stand there worrying about somebody's
statute if it fits your life on the line
it's just it's ridiculous that it's even
even a factor to be honest yeah i know
that they would tell you don't defend
your life like no you're better off just
sitting there and letting it happen like
come on
no man welcome to reality united states
that this is a culture that is literally
bent on punishing people for trying to
protect themselves and trying to prepare
for the future it's insane i think it's
because of suicide aggressive protection
like the romans they would kill everyone
around them to protect their home city
so there's a there's a whole discussion
about that i wanna i wanna read this one
but i'm gonna paraphrase it a little bit
liberty bell says
when the city libs get desperate enough
to work on farms the jobs will be taken
by the immigrants they fought to protect
i mean let's just be real
many of these uh undocumented illegal
immigrants these people are coming
through the border who are doing uh day
labor or working on farms
have more skills
so uh
i've been to the farms in california
where illegal immigrants are working and
they're getting paid they get paid like
10 bucks an hour
so if someone comes in the city and i
need a job i'm going to be like this guy
knows how to do it you don't can you
outwork this guy yeah it's not going to
happen
but i mean that's basically what happens
these days anyway once when these
factories try and hire people illegally
because they can pay them under market
under market prices
what's going to happen is they're going
to go to the farm we're like i heard you
guys need a poet on the farm
will you hire me for that the chickens
are bored i think yeah
i'm gonna read this one because heather
was right donut uh fighting says tim is
kind of right here masks work when used
properly i started as a nurse right as
covet started masks need to be disposed
of between patients
yes correct but it's also like
look
if i'm talking and then i i spit because
sometimes you do yeah you can get people
sick that way and if you're wearing a
mask you're not gonna spit on them but
mandating that every single person
whether they're sick or not has to wear
it and mandating every single child
whether their cigarette has to wear it
now that's just government overreach
yeah but you know that if you sneeze or
something in a mask the kind of mask
that we all wear
and you're and somebody stand next to
you they could have a mask on two if
their eyes are even open and those
particles it's like the the joke of if
you can smell the fart you're not
protected from the virus it's like the
particles of that virus are so smaller
than scent particles you know they're
gonna get out they're gonna float around
in the air for a minute because they
come out the tops and the sides that's
why that's why the fda called it a
experimental medical device when it
comes to stopping the virus
you know what up is it couldn't find it
i was trying to find it i i just think
in terms of the simplistic it'll provide
some protection to what degree that's
the debate it works for what it does
which is to block the spit that's the
main reason but is it like wearing a gas
mask no of course not but but my issue
ultimately comes down to i hate arguing
the science because i care more about
the liberty
going to children and be like we don't
care for sick where you got to weigh the
consequences of it for sure man well the
kids aren't if if they were like hey if
you're sick we want you to wear the mask
i'd be like well i kind of understand
that but if they're like we don't care
if the kid's sick or not i'm like okay
this is stupid well if your kid is sick
you don't send him to school come on
guys
i mean let's go right to that they're
like you're not feeling well yeah you
got oh you gotta you got a little
temperature you're staying home today
you know go on to school just wearing
your mask nobody says that all right
we're gonna read this one this one
beastly devil says tim
avosh video showed up last night where
he is if he's featured on a panel with
other political pundits he was making a
case for teaching kids about sex in
regards to promoting
abuse prevention uh no vosh come on
you're the last guy who should be
advocating for that stuff because well i
guess actually you're most people would
assume you would so if you're trying so
he he's got these quotes
that are suspect and he was like no
people are taken out of context i'm like
okay if you want to explain it that way
that was out of context you shouldn't be
doing things like that granted i didn't
see what this video is so but uh i
wouldn't be surprised if it was real
all right let's grab uh we'll try and
grab a couple more we've got so many
super chips man i'm wishing we should
read them all yeah
matthew greger says shout out to sheamus
tim you should have dr
saka uh
sakonicus from christendom
christendom college in front royal it
would make a great discussion that said
i have a soft spot for small liberal
arts colleges also sheamus i have an
icon for you if there's a good place to
mail it oh yeah thank you so much so i
think there's a p.o box right tim that
yeah i can send fan mail to so if you
find that on the website and i very much
appreciate the shout out thank you
timcast.com about section we have a p.o
box
all right
lotan volks says mr rich i was happy to
see you on the show thanks for being
strong and standing on your principles
like men should do
it is refreshing to hear to hear hear
you talk about your kids that way people
should fear coming for your kids because
there are a lot of people who are just
scared to stand up and they need to hear
they need to hear that strong sentiment
don't back down
i think you're you gotta man you gotta
put on your own oxygen mask before you
put on the masks of others that's
correct yeah you gotta make sure you're
taking care of your friends and your
family
all right we'll grab a couple more
john samuel says hey my name is sammy
mitchell producer songwriter here in
nashville produced to luke combs and
other stuff can i come hang on the cast
while you're in town reach out ig sammy
mitchell uh security is super tight here
and especially considering what's going
on been going on in the pa and these
past few months you know we got swatted
eight times or whatever plus the bomb
squad shut up so i don't know if we can
i i think that's gonna be a no but i
guess saturday can meet us down there
well yeah we'll we'll play some play
some music i'll tell you that luke combs
is one of the best new guys out there
yeah luke comes legit great country
singer yeah right on yeah well i think
this saturday sounds like we're gonna
we're gonna have a blast and we're gonna
have uh i guess effectively uh hang out
bring your id sami because other people
might tell me that they're sammy yeah
all right here we go let's um
what else what is it
karen bay says is a trust legal in new
jersey because nothing else is look it
up that's kind of what i was getting at
new jersey and maryland are dark states
when it comes to guns and i wouldn't
trust them well i just looked up
maryland it looks like it is an option
and some legal places can look at it for
you so cool just look at it for your
state right on well everybody make sure
you head over to timcast.com become a
member we're gonna have that members
only show coming up in just about an
hour we record it and then we upload it
and it goes up around 11 p.m eastern uh
as a member you're supporting our
journalists so don't forget to smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show if you really do
like it or if you're listening on the
podcast give us five stars you can
follow the show at tim cast irl
basically everywhere you can follow me
at tim cast uh you want to shout
anything out john uh if you want to
check out some of the stuff i'm doing go
to redneckriviera.com i've got a whiskey
in 13 000 stores across america uh 10
goes to the folds of honor which i'm
wearing their sweatshirt today they put
kids through college who lost a parent
in combat we've now funded over a
million dollars in three years to that
to that organization so check out that
site right on yeah man cool
i'm seamus i have a youtube channel
called freedom tunes where we make
cartoons political satire we're
releasing a very funny one tomorrow
about jill biden and one thursday about
these groomer teachers i think you guys
are going to enjoy it please subscribe
hit the notification bell check it out
i'm ian crossland hello everyone and
goodbye uh hey good to see you dude
great to meet you yeah this
yeah i am also here in the corner thank
you very much for coming john i have to
say you were activating memories that i
forgot i had because i loved songs like
the 8th of november i love
very a little bit scandalous but i love
save a horse riding cowboy
that was wild but i really enjoyed your
work so appreciate it so glad you could
come anyway you guys can follow me on
twitter at sarahpatchlids
and on mines.com and i also have sarah
patch lid stop me we will see you all at
timcast.com thanks for hanging out bye
guys
you